GONNA GO AHEAD AND CALL THIS
MEETING TO ORDER. CONVENE THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE I NEED TO
LOOSEN ENERGY HEARING SERGEANTS
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BEFORE WE WANTED AND I HAVE A
FEW HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENTS
TO MAKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDING
A FIX HE IS FROM COMMITTEE
TODAY. FOR MEDICAL REASONS AND
I WILL BE CHAIRING THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. WE HAVE A
FAMILY MEMBER CHAO'S THAT THE
MAN THANK YOU AND WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHILD. SECONDLY
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING OUR
COMMITTEE. HEARING TODAY THERE
WILL BE A MEETING OF THE
SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON THE OFFICE
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
MEMBERS LET'S KEEP IT AT LEAST.
AT LEAST THESE PEOPLE
RESPECTFUL PACE THIS AFTERNOON
RECOGNIZING THAT WE HAVE
ANOTHER COMMITTEE FOLLOWING US
IN THE CHAMBER. THIRD I WILL
MAINTAIN THEIR CRIME DURING THE
HEARING AS IT'S CUSTOMARY IN
ORDER TO HEAR AS MUCH FROM THE
PUBLIC WITHIN THE LIMITS OF OUR
TIME. WE WILL NOT PERMIT
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS THE
SERVICE OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. WE
WILL NOT ACCEPT THIS THAT THE
BEHAVIOUR AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS OUR SISTER UP THE- MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE CHAMBERS A
REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE
THEY CONNECTIONS NEEDED.
FINALLY WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN AN WAY
MASS AT ALL TIMES HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN PERSON. WE
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY.
FOR THE PEOPLE AND THE CHAMBER
OF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC. IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN THE BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND AND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME IASK THAT THE
PUBLIC METHODS A MICROPHONE. WE
ALSO HAVE WITNESSED VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS AVAILABLE
WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. FOR THE ALLEN
WITNESSES WILL BE EASY TO
MODERATE A TELEPHONE SERVICE
TODAY ALLOWING WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN IN
THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR TWO
SIX. TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
TILL AT THE ASSEMBLY UTILITIES
AND ENERGY COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON THE TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE FIND
TO DO SO OFTEN. TO DO S AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING AS- BEGINNING THEIR
PRESENTATION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU AE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL YOUR REMAIN
ON A LIVE LINE THEY WILL NEED
TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOUR
CALL TO SPEAK. YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
A FULL SERVICE IF YOU MAY CALL
THE COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO EIGHT
THREE. AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO HELP. WE ARE ALSO THAT
THE WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE AGENDA.
WE HAVE TEN MEASURES ON THE
AGENDA FOR OUR ON CONSENT AND
CONSENT WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB TWELVE FIFTY. CALDERON ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
ONE O'DONNELL ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB THIRTY THREE FIFTEEN. IN
ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY SIX HOLDEN. AS A PROCEED
WITH THAT WITNESS THE PUBLIC
COMMENT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THAT THIS
FAMILY HAS BILLS TO ENSURE WE
MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN AN
EFFICIENT HEARING. TESTIMONY IS
LIMITED TO FOUR MINUTES TOTAL
FOR EACH SIDE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ON THE
MEASURE PRIEST PLEASE BRIEFLY
STATE YOUR NAME POSITION AND
AFFILIATION IF ANY. I ALSO ASK
THE MEMBER SPEAK DIRECTLY INTO
YOUR MICROSOFT OUTLOOK CAN HEAR
YOUR VOTE. WE HAVE. TO KNOW.
OKAY A QUORUM IS NOT PRESENT
THEY WILL MOVE ON AS A SUB
COMMITTEE FOR NOW. WE'RE GOING
TO PROCEED ON FILE ORDER. OKAY
LET'S BEGIN WITH IT WE CAN
BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
FIVE TO FIVE FOR MR CHIU ENERGY
OFFSHORE WIND GENERATION. HE
SECURE READY. THANK YOU
MEDICARE LET ME FIRST START BY
THANKING CHAIRMAN HOLDEN AND
HIS COMMITTEE STAFF ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH ME AND MY
COALITION ON SIGNIFICAN
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL I AM
ACCEPTING ALL THE MOMENTS IN
THE ANALYSIS INCLUDING
AMENDMENTS DISTRICT PLANNING
TARGETS AND INSTEAD DIRECT THE
CDC TO IDENTIFY STATE GOALS FOR
LARGE SCALE AFTER A WIND IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN TO TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. AND MAKE IT EXPLICIT THAT
OFFER A WIN SHOULD BE DEVELOPED
IN A MANNER THAT PROTECTS
COASTAL AND MARINE ECOSYSTEMS
THIS IS A COMMITTEE THE KNOWS
FULL WELL THAT THIS PAST YEAR
ALONG WITH THE PANDEMIC IN THE
LOSS OF OVER A MILLION JOBS IN
OUR STATE CALIFORNIA HAS
EXPERIENCED INTENSE CLIMATE
CRISIS HEAT WAVES WILDFIRES
ROLLING BLACKOUTS AND MORE. AND
AS WE THINK ABOUT HOW TO
ADDRESS THIS CLIMATE CRISIS AND
PUT PEOPLE BACK TO WORK THERE
IS A ONCE IN A. GENERATION
OPPORTUNITY TO DO BOTH JUST
TWENTY TO THIRTY MILES OFF OUR
COAST CALIFORNIA'S ACCESS TO
ONE OF THE WORLD'S GREATEST
UNTAPPED RESOURCES OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY OFFSHORE WIND. WIND THAT
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO COMBAT
CLIMATE CHANGE MEET CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS AND PROVIDE GOOD
PAYING JOBS. THE BY
DEMONSTRATION HAS RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED SWEEPING INVESTMENTS
AND CLIMATE INFRASTRUCTURE.
INCLUDING PLANNING FOR THIRTY
GIGAWATTS OF OFFSHORE WIND BY
TWENTY THIRTY. ALONG WITH THREE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE INDUSTRY.
THIS PLAN ALSO EXPLORES
UNLOCKING A PATH TO A HUNDRED
AND TEN GIGAWATTS BY TWENTY
FIFTY. AND DESIGNATE SUITABLE
C. SPACE OFF THE EAST COAST.
EAST COAST DATES OF SEPT TWENTY
NINE GIGAWATT GOALS RESULTING
IN SIXTEEN PROJECTS UNDER
CONTRACT AND COUNTY. GIVEN THAT
OUR CAPACITY OF A HUNDRED AND
TEN GIGAWATTS IS ENOUGH TO MEET
ALL OF OUR ENERGY NEEDS. WE ARE
BEHIND AND WE NEED TO TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO STEP UP AND
ENSURE THAT WERE PART OF THIS
NATIONAL PLANS. OFFER WINDOWS A
SMART STRATEGY THAT COMPLEMENTS
OUR SOLAR INDUSTRY BECAUSE IT
GENERATES ENERGY AT NIGHT WHEN
SOLAR CANNOT. OFFSHORE WIND
ALSO HAS THE POTENTIAL TO ADD
THOUSANDS OF GOOD PAYING JOBS
IN SUPPLY CHAIN DEVELOPMENT
CONSTRUCTION OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE. THIS BILL AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE WOULD JUMPSTART THE
OFFSHORE WIND INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA BY CREATING A PLAN
TO CONSTRUCT AND HARNESS THE
POWER OF OFFSHORE WIND. IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE START
PLANNING NOW TO MEET THE GOALS
OF OUR STATE AND OUR COUNTRY
AND WITH THAT- REALLY
APPRECIATE THE STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE'VE HAD ON
THIS BILL. ON ONE HAND THINGS
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE IN JOINT
AUTHORS SIMPLY NUMBER
CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. I'D LIKE TO ECHO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE- WORDS
OF GRATITUDE TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING SO HARD ON THIS AND
TO- CHAIRMAN HOLDEN FOR HIS.
DEDICATION TO THE- LANDING THIS
BILL IN THE RIGHT PLACE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD- THE AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE IT WOULD FOR THE
FIRST TIME ACTUALLY FORMALIZE
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
OFFSHORE WIND POWER DEVELOPMENT
AND WHY IS THAT IMPORTANT WELL
CALIFORNIA HAS TO DIVERSIFY OUR
ENERGY PORTFOLIO TO MEET THE
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS WE'VE
SET FOR OURSELVES AN OFFSHORE
WIND IS A VITAL COMPONENT. TO
REACHING THAT GOAL. WE CAN LOOK
NO FURTHER THAN ACROSS THE POND
TO THE UNITED KINGDOM AS AN
EXAMPLE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. THE UNITED KINGDOM
HAS REDUCED ITS CO TWO
EMISSIONS MORE THAN ANY OTHER
DEVELOPED NATION IN THE WORLD.
THEY'VE DONE THAT BY INVESTING
IN AND BUILDING OFFSHORE WIND.
AS A DIRECT RESULT OF THEIR
INVESTMENT OFFICER WHEN THEY'VE
SEEN THOSE CLIMATE REDUCTIONS
THEIR ENERGY HAS GOTTEN CHEAPER
AND THEIR ENTIRE SOCIETIES
BENEFIT. CALIFORNIA'S A PERFECT
PLACE. TO DEVELOP THIS NEW
MARKET AN EXCITING TECHNOLOGY
WE HAVE WHEN THE BLOWS TWENTY
FOUR HOURS A DAY JUST THIRTY
FORTY MILES OFF OUR COAST. THE
PEAK PRODUCTION AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED AS AT NIGHT. WHEN THE
PEAK DEMAND IS ON THE GRIP.
THAT'S A NICE THING AND THAT'S
UNLIKE SOLAR WHICH IS WHY
COMPLIMENTS SO A VERY VERY VERY
WELL IF WE DON'T DO THIS AND WE
DON'T HAVE A PLAN WE FACE SOME
PRETTY DIRE CIRCUMSTANCES
COMING UP HERE IN TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IF
YOU DON'T KNOW OUR STATE'S LAST
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT DOUBLE
CANYON NUCLEAR POWER PLANT
WHICH IS IN MY DISTRICT IS
SLATED TO BE DECOMMISSIONED GO
OFFLINE WHEN THAT HAPPENS WE
WILL LOSE NEARLY 10% OF OUR
STATEWIDE ENERGY PRODUCTION.
OVERNIGHT SO WE GOT TO START
NOW AND PLANNING FOR HOW WE
REPLACED THE OUTLOOK AND ITS
POWER HOW WE GROW THE OFFSHORE
WIND. MARKET AND HOW CALIFORNIA
CAN LEAD THE WAY ON THE WEST
COAST. WITH THIS EXCITING NEW
TECHNOLOGY AND I SHOULD MENTION
LASTLY. THIS COULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF HIGH
PAYING JOBS. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING WE SHOULDN'T FORGET
EITHER AS WE MOVE FORWARD. I AM
GLAD IN GREAT GRATEFUL TO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU OUR OTHER
JOINT AUTHORS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. FOR TAKING A
LEADERSHIP ROLE ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. AND ENCOURAGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU I HAVE A
PROGRAM TO GO ANY. FURTHER IT'S
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
OTHER IS EXCEPT. SAN PATTERSON
HERE BEAR QUE HAN. BURKE CAREER
WE ARE HERE. CHELL CHECK OUT
HERE CHEN THIS POSITION HERE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM HERE
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES MURATSUCHI QUIRK QUIRKIER
REYES REYES HERE SANTIAGO. TANG
AS HERE. MAYES HERE. THAT'S
NINE. THANK YOU WE WILL PROCEED
WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITH
ASSISTANCE SYSTEM BY MY PHONE
FOR MODERATOR WE HAVE A LARA AT
THE END WITH THE ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU
TO HEAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM- AND
BY THE END STATE DIRECTOR AT
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE VERY PROUD AND EXCITED
YOU COSPONSORED AB FIVE TWO
FIVE- IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
I'M JUST HERE FOR QUESTIONS.
AND SO THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU FOR MODERATOR WE HAVE ALSO
JERRY SMITH WITH THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MODERATOR JEREMY
SMITH HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO PROUD CO
SPONSORS ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL. TO DRIVE UP CONSTRUCTION
APPRENTICESHIP SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA AND TO ADD ANOTHER
TOOL TO THE STATE'S TOOLBOX TO
LOWER GHG EMISSIONS. I ALSO
MORE THE TIME SHORT THERE'S
WHILE SIMPLY URGE YOU TO VOTE I
AM A PORTABLE DEVELOPMENT AND
ENERGY DIVERSIFICATION BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
FORMAL OPPOSITION LISTED WE
WILL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER FLOOR OR IN
THE BACK OF THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION. I AM
BETWEEN THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN AB FIVE TWO FIVE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS GOT
WHICH ON BEHALF THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS- STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE WEST
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE IN THE BUILDING. THE PHONE
LINES ARE NOW OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES HE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN AB FIVE TWO
FIVE. FULLER MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE OF THE LAND THAT
WAS TO SPEAK AND SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. OR SHARE THE
CONCERNS ON AB FIVE TWO FIVE.
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE TO FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GET THAT
THEIR LINE NUMBER. AND AGAIN IT
IT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE TWO FIVE. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE UP A THREE OH FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
ERIN WITH RODRIGUEZ THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE OUT OF
A- TWO SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON HERE
MEMBERS AND YOU WONDER WITH YOU
TO ENVIRONMENTAL ENTREPRENEURS
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FIVE TWO FIVE ON BEHALF
OF OUR TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
BUSINESS MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
TWO SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWO WEEKS AGO WITH THE
WHITE MAN GROUP ON BEHALF OF
OUR W. E. AND EAST BAY
COMMUNITY ENERGY INTO COURT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
TO GO TO LINE OF THE TWO FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON DILLON JACK ON BEHALF.
IN THE COURSE. THANK YOU NXR GO
TO LINE OF ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
JAMES THEREAFTER THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL WAIVERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MEXICO
CAROLINA OF ONE SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANIELLE OF CORNELL'S
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN CLEAN
POWER CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL- I ALSO
WANT TO CONVEY SUPPORT FROM THE
SEVERAL INDUSTRY GROUPS AND
COMPANIES. AKHIR OFFSHORE WIND
BUSINESS NETWORK FOR OFFSHORE
WIND CAPITALAND CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION THEIR
DEFENSE AND RENEWABLE ENERGY
STRATEGY EDF RENEWABLE ECUADOR
MAGELLAN WHEN MAINSTREAM
RENEWABLE POWER OFFSHORE WIND
CALIFORNIA OR DOES IT PRINCIPLE
POWER PACIFIC OCEAN ENERGY
TRUST AND RWE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. MEXICO CAROLINA TWO
EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YOU HAVE A SOME YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS WITH CONSTRUCTION
HAPPEN EACH CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE TWENTY FIVE
IS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU THAT
WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS JENNIFER GONZALEZ
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE OFFICE OF THE TREND THAT
GOVERNOR EL ANY. IN THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR IS PROUD TO
BE A CO SPONSOR AB FIVE TWO
FIVE WE THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ITS HARD WORK ON THE BILL AND
THE QUESTION I BUILT TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWO SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WEISSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
NUCLEAR RESPONSIBILITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NXR GO TO LINE UP TO NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JERRY ON
THE BRIGHTLINE DEFENSE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NXR
GO TO A LINE OF ONE OF THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS EMMA KELLER SENIOR FIELD
REPRESENTATIVE FOR CARPENTERS
LOCAL SEVEN FIFTY ONE AND
THIRTY FIVE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COVERING MARANTZ AND
NO MY NAPA LAKE MENDOCINO DEL
NORTON HUMBOLDT COUNTY'S AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF ONE OF SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON NO WELL
CARRILLO MILL RIGHT. LOCAL
WINNER TO FIELD WORKERS SENATOR.
CRESENT AND ALL FORTY SIX
COUNTIES IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE SUPPORT. EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP TO TWO
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MANY HUNTERS EXPLOSION WIND IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEXICO TIMELINE OF ONE OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TIMOTHY RIGHT
CARPENTERS LOCAL TWENTY TWO IN
SAN FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
UP ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ED EVANS OF CARPENTERS UNION
LOCAL TWO SEVENTEEN SAN MATTEO
COUNTY. CALLING TO VOICE OUR
MEMBERS STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NXR GOTO LINE OF ONE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
SORRY THEY'RE NOT THERE WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF TWO NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS DOUG
SERVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
BOILERMAKERS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. EXTROVERT A
LINE OF ONE THIRTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MARIE
TEN I'M A RESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT. EIGHTY
FIVE TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
MEXICO TIMELINE OF THREE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON RT BELCHER WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS
REGIONAL COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. FIVE FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU NET SERVER ONE OF
THREE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE THREE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MELISSA ROMERO AT
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU. THE
NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF THREE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS SEAN HEBARD
REPRESENTING UP THAT MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS LOCAL FIVE OH FIVE AND
SIX OF FIVE OF SANTA CRUZ AND
MONTEREY COUNTIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE TWO FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
ACCESSIBLE TO LINE OF THREE
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE THREE FOUR FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS RALPH DENNIS REPRESENTING
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO MORE
SUPPORT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
OPPOSITION. MODERATOR THANK YOU
FOR IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF AB. FIVE
TWO FIVE. I SHOW NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION AT THE TIME. THANK
YOU DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR A MISTRIAL
IF AND THE SECOND FROM S. KOREA
AND MR MARTUCCI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I JUST WANT TO. COMMEND
THE AUTHORS OF THIS IMPORTANT
BILL YOU KNOW WE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT HOW WE NEED TO HAVE A
JUST TRANSITION TO GET MORE-
YOU KNOW GOOD UNION LABOR
BUILDING ARE RENEWABLE- UTILITY
SCALE PROJECTS AND SO THIS IS.
AN EMBODIMENT OF THAT EFFORT-
WITH YOUR- APPROVAL THIS ISSUE
I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
OUR QUE HAN YEAH IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I TO
JUST WANT TO THANK- THE
AUTHORED HIS JOIN AUTHOR FOR
AND PRESENTING THIS BILL TODAY
I THINK IT'S SO CRITICAL AS I
SAID IN OUR PREVIOUS HEARING
AND I KNOW MANY OF US AGREED
THAT WE LOOK AT ALL THE
PASSWORD TO A CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE IN THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THAT PUZZLE.
BEING CALIFORNIA HAVING THIS
RESOURCE ON OUR DOORSTEP AND
NOT USING IT TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT FEELS. LIKE NOT THE
RIGHT THING TO DO AND SO I'M
GLAD YOU'RE MOVING THIS FORWARD
I YOU KNOW. I WISH YOU'RE DOING
IT IN A MORE AGGRESSIVE WAY BUT
WE ARE WHERE WE ARE AND I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT. AND I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW I. THE
THING ME UP AT NIGHT
IS MY CHILDREN'S FUTURE. AND
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WILL HAVE A WORLD THAT
THEY CAN HAVE IT THAT IS SAFE.
AND AGAIN THIS IS JUST A STEP%
IN MAKING SURE DOING EVERYTHING
IN OUR POWER TO ENSURE THAT
FUTURE FOR OUR CHILDREN SAID
THANK YOU MISTER CHIP. THANK
YOU- MISTER. MISTER PATTERSON
ARE VICE CHAIR JUST. THE
OPPOSITION THAT WAS PRIMARILY-
ON THE BILL- WAS BASICALLY THAT
CALIFORNIA LARGE ENERGY- USERS
A LOT OF AGRICULTURAL FOLKS-
AND I'VE HAD- SIGNIFICANT
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM AND
ALTHOUGH THEY HAVE REMOVED IT
THERE- OPPOSITION THERE ARE
UNDERLYING. CONCERNS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO WANT TO- HAVE
CONSIDERED AS AS THIS MOVES TO
THE- TO THE BILL- STAGE WITH
WITH RESPECT TO WHAT HAPPENS AT
THE AT THE- WHAT WITH THE PLAN
HERE SO- I'M GONNA LAY OFF THE
BILL PRESENTLY- RESERVE MY-
WHICH ON THE FLOOR- BUT DO
WATER. REMIND FOLKS THAT. IT IS
AGRICULTURE AND IT IS THE
MARGIN OF G. USERS- THAT OFTEN
HAVE- THEIR RATES INCREASED AS
A RESULT OF SOME OF THE RENEWAL
SO WE'VE SEEN THAT- FAIRLY
REGULARLY- AND SO I THERE THERE
ARE SOME STILL LATENT CONCERNS
AND- FOR THAT REASON A LAYOFF
PRESENTLY. THANK YOU MISTER
CUNNINGHAM YEAH WITH CHAIRS
INTELLIGENCE VEGAS THANK THE
VICE CHAIR FOR RAISING THAT
ISSUE IS ALWAYS A STRONG.
PROPONENT FOR AG AND- I AM AS
WELL RIGHT TRY TO BE JUST A
COUPLE THOUGHTS FOR
CONSIDERATION ON THAT I MEAN.
THE MORE ENERGY WE CAN PRODUCE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
LESS RELIANT WE WILL BE ON
IMPORTED ENERGY FROM OUT OF
STATE AND WE HAVE MAJOR. GRID
RESILIENCY PROBLEMS EVEN TODAY.
AND THAT IS WE'RE ONLY LESS
THAN FOUR YEARS AWAY FROM
LOSING AGAIN. THE LAST NUCLEAR
PLANT WHICH IS 10% OF THE
STATE'S POWER NOW TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN THREE SIXTY FIVE. SO I
THINK. IN TERMS OF INCREASING
SUPPLY TO MATCH SUPPLY AND
DEMAND AND KEEP THE GRID
RESILIENCE I THINK. THAT
ANYTHING WE DO TO PRODUCE OR
STORE. MORE ELECTRONS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE WERE WE
ARE CONTRIBUTING TO GRID
RESILIENCY WHICH WILL HELP KEEP
COSTS DOWN BECAUSE- AS WE'VE
LEARNED AND GOING BACK. TWENTY
YEARS OR SO OR MAYBE NINETEEN
YEARS WHATEVER IT WAS THE LAST
ENERGY CRISIS I MEAN. WE CAN
END UP AS A STATE AND A VERY
BAD PLACE IF WE END UP. RELYING
ON OUT OF STATE IMPORTED POWER
BECAUSE- WE NEED TO COVER THAT
LAST 1% AND THEN WE'RE AT THE
MERCY OF WHATEVER SOMEBODY
FROM. A PRODUCER FROM ANOTHER
STATE ONCE ONCE THE CHARGER CAN
LEGALLY CHARGE AND I DON'T WANT
END UP BACK THERE AGAIN SO I
SEE THIS AS- ACTUALLY
SUPPORTIVE OF AG. AS AN
INDUSTRY WHICH HAS A LARGE
CONSUMER OF ENERGY IN A LARGE
PURCHASER- BECAUSE I THINK IT
WILL INCREASE OVER TIME FOR
ABLE TO BUILD THIS OUT TO THE
SCALE- WE'RE HOPING TO. IN
TERMS OF OFFSHORE WIND
GENERATION IT WILL CONTRIBUTE
POSITIVELY TO GRID RELIABILITY
AND HOLD PRICES DOWN THE LONG
RUN. AS ONE TO MAKE THAT
OBSERVATION. THANK YOU SEEN ALL
FURTHER COMMENT- MR SHE WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. L. PERSONALLY
JUST APPRECIATE. THE COMMENTS
AND ALL THE FEEDBACK TO THE
PROCESS AND- WE HAVE BEEN
ENGAGING WITH THE LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
DO SO I WANT TO JUST MAKE A FEW
POINTS ON THAT- IF WE ARE
SUCCESSFUL- THE IDEA IS THAT.
AS OFFER WIND IS COMMERCIALIZED
WE ARE EXPECTING ENERGY COSTS
TO FALL SO OUR HOPE IS. AS WE
MOVE THIS FORWARD COSTS WILL BE
REDUCED WE ALSO KNOW THAT. WE
NEED TO ADD OFFER WIND IS PART
OF A DIVERSE PORTFOLIO SO THAT
WE CAN STABILIZE- THE ENERGY
SOURCES THAT WE HAVE- THERE WAS
AN SB ONE HUNDRED JOINT AGENCY
REPORT- THAT HAD REPORTED THAT
WITHOUT OFFSHORE WIND. TOTAL
ENERGY COSTS BECOME A BILLION
DOLLARS MORE EXPENSIVE IN THE
FUTURE- BECAUSE OF REASONS WE
STATED BEFORE. GIVEN THE TIME
WHEN THE SENATE IS PRODUCED AT
IN THE EVENING TO GET A
COMPLIMENTS WHAT'S HAPPENING
SILVA. LET ME ALSO JUST AND BY
ECHOING THE COMMENTS OF OUR
EAST BAY COLLEAGUE- LIKE HER
AND LIKE MANY OF YOU. I HAVE A
YOUNG CHILD AND WE KNOW AT THIS
MOMENT WE HAVE TO ACT NOW WHEN
IT COMES TO THIS CRISIS AND I
REALLY WANT TO THANK- THE
SIGNIFICANT COALITION OF
ENVIRONMENTALISTS. THE CLEAN
ENERGY INDUSTRY AS WELL AS
LABOR FOR COMING TOGETHER. TO
MOVE FORWARD THIS VISION NOT
JUST FOR OFFER WIN BUT WHAT A
JUST TRANSITION MEANS. HI THIS
IS GOING TO BE INSTRUMENTAL FOR
US TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CRISIS.
AND ALSO CREATE THE JOBS THAT
WE NEED TO FOR THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY ECONOMY THAT WE WANT TO
CALIFORNIA. AND WITH THAT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU SIX PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I AND NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO NATURAL RESOURCES. ESTINA
GARCIA HI CRISTINA GARCIA I
PATTERSON. PATTERSON NOT VOTING
BEAR CAN BETTER QUE HANNAH HI
BURKE. BURKE AYE CORREA CORREO
I SHALL CHAU CHEN. CHEN AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I EDUARDO
GARCIA. MAYES MAYES AYE
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI ARTWORK.
QUARTER I REYES. REYES I
SANTIAGO. KING. AISA LEVIN
SERRANO'S. INDIANAPOLIS I'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT ITEM DO WE HAVE A
MOTION A CONSENSUS. MOVED BY
MISTRAS SECOND MY MISTER
CUNNINGHAM. I DON'T SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB TWELVE FIFTY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSES AMENDED TO
NATURAL RESOURCES. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB THIRTY THREE. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. ADAM NUMBER
TEN A. B. ELEVEN FIFTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CRISTINA GARCIA
HI CRISTINA GARCIA I PATTERSON
SAN AYE BARRICADE CAN. AMERICA
HAD AYE BURKE. BURKE I CARILLO
CORREO I CHAU. CHEN CHEN I'D
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I EDUARDO
GARCIA. MAYES MAYES I
MURATSUCHI MESSAGES AYE CORK.
WORK IRATE IS REYES I SANTIAGO.
KING. IS TEN ZERO KNOWS. THANK
YOU THOSE ARE OUT WILL BE THERE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE. BYE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ. ENERGY CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATE RATES FOR ENERGY
PROGRAM NET ENERGY METERING
ELECTRICAL CORPORATION
DISTRIBUTED ELIGIBLE RENEWABLE
ENERGY RESOURCE ALLOCATION
INTERCONNECTIONS MISS GONZALEZ
YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU- MADAM
CHAIR AT FIRST I WANT TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OR THE REWRITE OF MY
BILL- AS DESCRIBED IN THE NOW
SAYS AND THINK THE CHAIRED
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR VERY
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL. AB
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE THE FULLER
EQUITY IN REGULAR PAYER RELIEF
ACT WOULD PHASE OUT
CALIFORNIA'S INEQUITABLE ENERGY
RATE STRUCTURES IF THE CPUC
FAILS TO ADOPT NM THREE BY NEXT
YEAR AND MAKE OTHER MUCH NEEDED
CHANGES PER CUSTOMER
GENERATORS. CALIFORNIA FIRST
INTRODUCED NETWORK ENERGY
METERING TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCENTIVIZE THE ADOPTION OF
REACH TOP SOLAR WHICH AT THE
TIME WAS A PLEDGING INDUSTRY.
UNDER NAM CUSTOMERS NOT ONLY
HAVE LOWER BILLS BECAUSE
THEY'RE USING LESS ENERGY FROM
THE GRID BUT ALSO FROM THE
CREDITS THEY RECEIVE FOR
SELLING BACK THEIR ACCESS POWER
THE RETAIL RATES TO UTILITY. I
KNOW THIS FIRSTHAND BECAUSE I
ALSO IN ME ROOFTOP SOLAR
CUSTOMER HOWEVER STUDIES DONE
BY THE C. U. P. HAVE FOUND THAT
THEY ACROSS THE STATE ROOFTOP
SOLAR CUSTOMERS ARE
CONSISTENTLY BENEFITING FROM
THE RATE STRUCTURE MORE THAN
THE VALUE OF THE ENERGY
GENERATION SOLAR CUSTOMERS ARE
ABLE TO AVOID PAYING THEIR FAIR
SHARE. OF FIXED COSTS TO THE
GREAT BY AVOIDING ENERGY USAGE
CHARGES DESPITE ALL OF US
INCLUDING SOLAR CUSTOMER STILL
RELYING ON GRID INFRASTRUCTURE
THOSE COSTS ARE THEN SHIFTED TO
OTHER RATEPAYERS IN A RULE
MAKING PROCEDURE BEFORE THE
CPUC THE STATEWIDE KASHIF WITH
ESTIMATED ROUGHLY THREE BILLION
DOLLARS AND EXPECTED TO GROW TO
FOUR POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
BY TWENTY THIRTY. A RECENT
STUDY BY UC BERKELEY IN TOUGH
FOUND THAT EVEN AFTER
CONTROLLING FOR INCOME AND HOME
OWNERSHIP BLACK AND LATINO
NEIGHBORHOODS HAD LESS ROOFTOP
SOLAR INSTALLED IN WHITE
MAJORITY NEIGHBORHOODS LEADING
THEM TO BE DISPROPORTIONATELY
BEAR THE BURDEN OF THIS COST
SHIFT. AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE IS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED WOULD
REFORM THE KASHIF AND REQUIRE
CUSTOMER GENERATORS TO BE
CREDITED FOR ENERGY EXPORTS AT
WHOLESALE MARKET RATES THE SAME
AS ANY OTHER GENERATOR N. B.
CHARGE FIXED FEES TO COVER THE
NON GENERATION COSTS OF SERVING
THE CUSTOMER. THIS SUCCESSOR
CHERUB. WOULD GO INTO EFFECT
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
WHEN THREE ALL. IF THE C. P.
HAS FAILED DOCTORS. TO PROVIDE
AMPLE UPPER TO ALLOW THE C. P.
TO ACT. THE AMENDMENTS WHICH
EXIT NUMBER. TO THE SIX CARE OF.
NO LATER THAN FIVE YEARS AFTER
IN. OR TEN YEARS FOR CARE
CUSTOMERS. THE AMENDMENTS WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE. WAGE FOR
INSTALLING NEW RENO ENERGY FOR.
AFTER THIRD FIRST TWO TWENTY.
IN REQUIRE THE C. P. U. C. H.
INCLUDING. ON THE GROWTH OF
RESIDENTIAL ROOFTOP SOLAR AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THEIR ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE. BY CHARGING SOLAR
CUSTOMERS THEIR FAIR SHARE AB
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE WOULD
GREATLY REDUCED RATES FOR NON
THEM CUSTOMERS WE CAN'T
CONTINUE TO PUSH COSTS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SERVES
EVERYONE. ONTO NON SOLAR
CUSTOMERS FURTHER EXASPERATING
ANY INEQUITIES IN THE STATE
BOTH FINANCIALLY AND IN ACCESS
TO RENEWABLE ENERGY. AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE WOULD PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED REFORM I HAVE I HAD TO
WITNESSES ON THE PHONES I
BELIEVE. SCOTT WHICH EMERGES
THAT. WHO MADAM CHAIR MEMBER
SCOTT WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS. AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
IS ABOUT CORRECTING GROSS
INJUSTICES. 91% OF ALL YOUR
RATE PAYERS ARE SUBSIDIZING THE
9% OF NEW CUSTOMERS TO THE TUNE
OF MORE THAN THREE BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. AT LEAST ONE
THIRD OF THAT WINDFALL DOESN'T
EVEN GO TO RATEPAYERS AT ALL HE
GOES TO BIG CORPORATIONS LIKE
TESLA AND SUNRUN. WELL
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN LEFT BEHIND. YOU ALL THE
SEEN THE UC BERKELEY STUDY ON
THE RACIAL INEQUALITY OF OUR
SOLAR PROGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE IN
RANCHO SANTA FE ONE OF THE
STATE'S WEALTHIEST COMMUNITIES.
15% OF ALL RATEPAYERS AROUND
THEM WELL IN THE FIVE POOREST
ZIP CODES AND CA DIEGO IT'S A
LITTLE MORE THAN 1% THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR INITIATIVE
PROGRAM SPENT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS SUBSIDIZING ROOFTOP
SOLAR AND LESS THAN 2% WENT TO
LOW INCOME AFFORDABLE OR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING. WELL 98% WENT
TO WEALTHY COMMUNITIES AND BIG
CORPORATIONS. IN ADDITION TO
THIS ABSURD WINDFALL THE 91% OF
RATE PAYERS ARE BURDENED WITH
PAYING ALL THE SYSTEM COSTS
THAT THE 9% AVOID. ITS REVERSE
ROBIN HOOD. MAKE NO MISTAKE AS
YOUR ANALYSIS CORRECTLY POINTS
OUT THIS IS ABOUT LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY BEING RESPECTED EIGHT
YEARS AGO THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSED AB THREE TWENTY SEVEN.
DIRECTING THE CPUC TO FIX THIS
COST SHIFT AND THEY HAVE FAILED
TO COMPLY AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
HOLDS THE COMMISSION'S FEET TO
THE FIRE FINALLY. THIS BILL
APPLIES PREVAILING WAGE TO THIS
PROGRAM BECAUSE ACCORDING TO
THE BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS
SOLAR INSTALLERS MAKE BETWEEN
ELEVEN DOLLARS AND FIVE CENTS
AND TWENTY BUCKS AN HOUR WITH
LITTLE TO NO BENEFITS. THIS IS
NOT LIVABLE. DON'T BE SWAYED BY
WEALTHY CELEBRITIES PAGE
SPOKESPEOPLE FOR SUN RUN AND
ARE NOT LICENSED CONTRACTORS IN
CALIFORNIA. IF YOU'RE SINCERE
ABOUT CREATING GOOD GREEN JOBS
PLEASE VOTE FOR AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU NEXT ART
WE HAVE MARKET ALSO WITH ADAMS
BROADWELL JOSEPH AND CARDOSO
YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THIS BILL
WOULD GIVE THE COMMISSION A
DEADLINE TO MAKE A LONG OVER
DUE COURSE CORRECTION IN A
ROOFTOP SOLAR PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY REPAIRS WITHOUT SOLAR
PAY RATE PAYERS WITH SOLAR AT
THE FULL RETAIL RATE. IS THE
COMMITTEE MET ANALYSIS
DOCUMENTS ON PAGE THREE. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ALONE NET ENERGY
METERING IS SHIFTING COSTS TO
THOSE WITHOUT. TO THE TUNE OF
MORE THAN THREE BILLION DOLLARS
AND GROWING. THIS IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE. THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WOULD ADDRESS THE
CURRENT KASHIF BY WINNING
EXISTING THEM CUSTOMERS OFF THE
CURRENT RATE. OR THAT MORE THAN
ONE THIRD THE CURRENT CUSTOMERS
ARE SOLD TO COMPANIES
THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEY LEASE
THE ROOF AND RETAIN OWNERSHIP
OF THE SYSTEM. FOR CARE
CUSTOMERS MORE THAN HALF ARE
OWNED BY THE COMPANIES. THEY
JUST PASS ON A SMALL SAVINGS TO
THE RESIDENT. THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ALSO REQUIRE THE FUTURE
NAME SYSTEMS BECAUSE SCRIPTED
USING THE PREVAILING WAGE THIS
IS TOTALLY JUSTIFIED. THE LARGE
SCALE SYSTEMS THAT SUPPLY
UTILITIES AND CCA'S ARE ALMOST
ALL BUILT WITH PREVAILING WAGE
AND THEY ONLY COST THREE CENTS
A KILOWATT HOUR SO THERE'S NO
QUESTION. ABOUT THE COST TO
PREVAILING WAGE. AND ALSO WE
CAN'T FORGET THAT THE BIGGEST
SOURCE OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS S. TRANSPORTATION. WE
NEED ALECTRA CITY TO BE THE
FUEL OF CHOICE TO REDUCE
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS. BUT
NET ENERGY METERING IS DRIVING
UP RATES SO MUCH THAT WE DON'T
DO SOMETHING ELECTRICITY WILL
COST MORE THAN GASOLINE AND
DIESEL INSTEAD OF LESS. FINALLY
THE BILL AS AMENDED BY THE
COMMITTEE WILL NOT KILL THE
SOLAR INDUSTRY. REMINDER
COMMITTEE WHICH YOU ALL KNOW
WHICH IS THAT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION HAS REQUIRED SOLAR
ON NEW CONSTRUCTION. SO THEY'LL
BE PLENTY OF ROOFTOP SOLAR IN
THE FUTURE IT JUST WON'T COME
AT THE EXPENSE OF PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE ROOFTOP SOLAR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TESTIFYING BY PHONE. PHONE
MODERATOR WE HAVE TROY CARROLL.
YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. JERRY GARCIA BY FIVE
SHARE PATTERSON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY MY NAME
IS FOR CAROL AND I LIVE IN
BAKERSFIELD AND I URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE.
I'M A KERN COUNTY LOCAL WERE
GROWING UP THERE WERE TWO MAJOR
JOB OPPORTUNITIES FARMING AND
OIL. I CHOSE ALL. IF YEARS AGO
FACING THE UPS AND DOWNS OF OIL
BUSINESS AND CONSTANT TRAVEL I
WAS LOOKING FOR MORE STEADY A
PROMISING WORK TO SUPPORT MY
FOUR KIDS AND KEEP A CLOSE TO
HOME. I FOUND THAT JOBS IN THE
ROOFTOP SOLAR INDUSTRY THIS IS
THE FUTURE. BUT AT ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE THREATENS MY JOB
AND THE JOB OF HIM BUT
THOUSANDS OF OTHER SOLAR
WORKERS LIKE ME. I'M NOT ALONE
IN MY STORY. HALF OF MY CO
WORKERS TRANSITION FROM OIL TO
SOLAR. WHICH IS TESTAMENT TO
HOW LARGE A CENTRAL VALLEY
SOLAR MARKET IS. BAKERSFIELD IN
FACT IS THIRD IN THE STATE FOR
ROOFTOP SOLAR INSTALLING ALMOST
AS MUCH OF LOS ANGELES AND SAN
DIEGO. THIS IS A GOOD THING. A
LOT OF POLITICIANS FROM JOE
BIDEN THE GOVERNOR NEWSOM
WONDER HOW WE ARE GOING TO
TRANSITION FROM FOSSIL FUELS.
TO CLEAN ENERGY JOBS. WELL IN
BAKERSFIELD. THAT TRANSITION
IT'S ALREADY HAPPENING. THAT IS
UNLESS AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
PASSES. NOW I WANT TO BE CLEAR
I AM NOT AGAINST OIL JOBS I AM
FOR SOLAR JOBS I THINK WE NEED
TO TRANSITION TO CLEAN ENERGY.
BUT THE TRANSITION NEEDS TO BE
STATIC IT NEEDS TO BE REAL AND
IT NEEDS TO BE FELT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WE CAN'T HAVE OUR
CALIFORNIA'S BALL FOR ROOFTOP
SOLAR ONE DAY AND THEN THE NEXT
DAY IF NOT. CALIFORNIA CAN'T BE
PERSONAL WORK IN LIMITED
SITUATIONS FOR NARROW SET OF
CONSUMERS. EIGHTY ELEVEN THIRTY
NINE O'CLOCK CALIFORNIA TO GO
FROM BUILDING ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND SOLAR ROOFS A
YEAR. TO LESS THAN TWENTY
THOUSAND. THIS WOULD NOT BE
ENOUGH TO SUPPORT MY JOB I'M
NOT SURE. WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS
DONE THROUGH NET METERING
DISCRETE CONSISTENT RULES FOR
CONSUMERS BUSINESSES AND
WORKERS TO PLAN AROUND THESE
CONSISTENT RULES CAN BE
CHANGED. BUT THE CHANGES NEED
TO BE SLOW AND GRADUAL SO THERE
IS TIME TO ADJUST TO GROW INTO
THEM. AND THEY CAN'T BE
RETROACTIVE. I THINK THAT IS
WHAT BOTHERS ME THE MOST ABOUT
EIGHTY ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. IT
WOULD HAVE CALIFORNIA GO BACK
ON HIS WORD TO THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE MADE THE INVESTMENT IN
CLEAN ENERGY. AND YOU JUST
CAN'T DO THAT. THE LAST POINT I
WANT TO MAKE IT AROUND THE
PURPORTED COST SHIFT. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THE FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
KERN COUNTY BECAUSE CONSULAR.
ARE NOT WEALTHY. THEY INVESTED
IN SOLAR BECAUSE IT IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO AND BECAUSE
THEY ARE FED UP WITH P. GENIES
PROBLEMS. THE WILDFIRES.
COMMENTS BANKRUPTCIES. THE HIGH
ENERGY BILLS THEY WANT CHOICES
THEY WANT SOLUTIONS. THAT PG&E
IS TRYING TO BLAMES COLOR USERS
FOR THEIR PROBLEMS THAT THEY
HAVE CREATED WILL BE LAUGHABLE
IF IT WASN'T SO DEADLOCKED. IN
CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT BRAD HEAVEN OR THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
SOLAR AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION
IS ALSO ON THE LINE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. PLEASE
DO NOT KILL MYSELF A JOB.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON AT ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE HAVE JONATHAN SCOTT
WITH SCOTT BROTHERS GLOBAL.
MODERATOR THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU SERVICIOS VICE CHAIR
PATTERSON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT YOU SPEAKING TO
ME I- BY JONATHAN SCOTT I LIVE
IN LOS ANGELES AND I JUST WANNA
SAY RIGHT OFF THE TOP I OPPOSE
AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE ELECTED
THE POTENTIALLY AMENDED I'LL
TELL YOU WHY I HAVE A VERY
UNIQUE BACKGROUND IN THE HOME
AND ENERGY SPACE THAT SEPARATE
THAT FROM RENOVATING OVER FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY HOMES ARE SHOW
PROPERTY BROTHERS I HELP THOSE
FAMILIES BUT ALSO IT'S BEEN
THREE YEARS OF MY LIFE
TRAVELING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
FOR MY DOCUMENTARY POWER TRIP.
THAT EXAMINE THE WAR BETWEEN
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY AND
RENEWABLE ENERGY COMPANY AND I
INTERVIEWED HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
FROM VARIOUS STATE EVERY WALK
OF LIFE YOU CAN IMAGINE AND
PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING SOME
PEOPLE HAVE TO CHOOSE WHETHER
OR NOT TO PAY THEIR POWER BILLS
FOR TO PAY FOR FOOD ON THE
TABLE FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND
THAT IS CRAZY. THAT THAT'S
HAPPENING IN AMERICA AND THERE
ARE TWO THINGS THAT REALLY
STOOD OUT TO ME ON A JOURNEY
ONE IS THAT IN ENERGY IS BEING
MADE INTENTIONALLY COMPLICATED
WHEN IT DOES NOT NEED TO BE
THERE ARE SOLUTIONS THAT WOULD
BE GOOD FOR UTILITIES AND THEIR
WORKERS AND THAT A VERY
IMPORTANT THING IN CREATING NEW
JOBS BUT ALSO PROTECTING THE
JOB THAT WE ALREADY HAVE- BUT
AT ALL QUICK TO BE GOOD FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL ESPECIALLY LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND THE
SECOND BIG THING THAT I
DISCOVERED IS THAT THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY LOOKED UP TO
CALIFORNIA WHEN IT COMES TO
RENEWABLE ENERGY. IT WAS
AMAZING TO ME THAT THEY SAW
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER AND WHEN
I MOVED TO CALIFORNIA I WAS
PROUD TO BE A PART OF A STATE
THAT HAD THAT KIND OF FORWARD
THINKING I LIVED IN NEVADA AND
I LIVED THROUGH THE NET
METERING DISASTER IN THE NEVADA
AND ONE OF THE VENGEFULLY
OVERTURNED NEVER IN MY LIFE
HAVE I SEEN A CATASTROPHIC
RESPONSE TO APPEASE THE BAD
LEGISLATION LIKE THAT THE
PUBLIC OUTCRY WAS INCREDIBLE
EVERYBODY FULLER CUSTOMERS AND
NON CORE CUSTOMERS WERE UPSET
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT THE IMPACT
OF WHAT WAS HAPPENING. AND I
THINK IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE GOING
DOWN THE SAME PATH EXCEPT THE
RESULT WILL BE EVEN WORSE
BECAUSE PEOPLE EXPECTING
CALIFORNIA THAT WE'RE GOING TO
FOLLOW POLICY THAT SUPPORT
CLEAN AFFORDABLE ENERGY ACCESS.
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS- COMMITTEE
CRICKET BUILD LUMPING TO. THAT
THINGS THAT SHOULD NOT BE DEALT
WITH TOGETHER. THERE IS AN ECHO
ISSUE IN. BUT THIS IS NOT HOW
SOLVE IT. AND WE WOULD ASK YOU
SEE A NET JOB LOSS IN THE STATE.
IF WE WENT WITH THE BILL THE
IT'S WRITTEN. AND FRANKLY NOT
ME DOES NEED ENOUGH. BUT OTHER
THREAT IT WOULD ACTUALLY
EXACERBATE THE ISSUE. AND
EFFECTIVELY CANCEL OUT ANY.
SAVINGS FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS IF YOU WANT ROOF TOP.
THE OTHER. THAT IT'S BEEN TWO
MINUTES HE PLEASE READ UP. YES
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE
WOULD NOT BE A LEADER WE GROUP
WE GO THIS PATH WE WOULD FALL
TO THE BOTTOM OF THE PACK AND
YOU KNOW AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
IS TALKING SOME OF THE RIGHT.
THING THAT I DO AGREE WITH A
LOT OF HARD WORK BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE NEED TO REALLY THINK
CAREFULLY BECAUSE THIS WOULD
CREATE A LARGER IMBALANCE AND
WE'RE EVEN SEEING NOW SO I'D
SAY PLEASE VOTE NO. AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT
AS A REMINDER YOU MUST KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO JUST YOUR
NAME. ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
SUPPORT OPPOSE OR OTHER
COMMENTATORS YOU DEVIATE FROM
THIS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT THIS MEETING
WILL BE ROLLED OUT OF ORDER AND
WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
PERSON. I ALSO WANT TO SALAS
THAT WHAT HAS BEEN AGREED NOT
WHAT HAS BEEN AGREED TO ON THIS
MEASURE. THIS BILL IS BEING
AMENDED AND WILL NOT ELIMINATE
SOLAR OR THE NET ENERGY
METERING TERRA. PLEASE KEEP
THIS IN MIND AS YOU'RE MAKING
YOUR STATEMENT. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER. ARE IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OR IN
BETWEEN FOR AB THIRTEEN ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE. SEEN AND NINE WE
WILL MOVE ON. THE PHONE LINES
ARE NOW OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ON AB ELEVEN THIRTY
NINE BEFORE WE BEGAN- I WANT TO
REMIND INDIVIDUALS THAT WE HAVE
FOR BILLS LEFT AND WE NEED TO
CLEAR THE CHAMBERS BY FOUR
THIRTY FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S CONFIRMING HEARING.
BECAUSE OF THIS WE WILL NEED TO
LIMIT SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION TO
A TOTAL OF THIRTY MINUTES. FOR
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY ONE ON
THE LINE THAT WSHES TO SPEAK
EITHER IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OR SHARE THEIR CONCERNS ON AB
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE WE WILL TAKE
ALL POSITIONS AT THE SAME TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU. AND IF YOU
WERE. IN OPPOSITION. OR
SUPPORT. OF AB ELEVEN THIRTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
EIGHTY IN FEWEST MOMENTS. THANK
YOU AGAIN I REMIND INDIVIDUALS
TO PLEASE ONLY STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION
ANYTHING FURTHER I WILL AFTER
MODERATOR TO MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT INDIVIDUAL THANK YOU. WOOD
LET'S BEGIN. OKAY WELL GO TO
LINE OF THREE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE THREE EIGHT
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT
THE DROPS WILL GO TO THE LINE
OF ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE
MOMENT.
FORMER LINE OF A- ONE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONLY
PUSH TO ONE AND THEN ZERO ONE
TIME. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M SORRY MANAGER ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. LINE THREE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS THE ONLY BE USED I WORK FOR
A COMPANY ALONG WITH CENTRAL
COAST AND I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED
THE AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. YEAH
COMMITTEE. IT WELL YEAH I MEAN
YOU MAKE A PERSON. LINE FOUR
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
GARRETT I AM PART OF THE
CHARACTERS CLIMATE ACTION
NETWORK AND ALSO. ALLIANCE FOR
COMMUNITY ENERGY I'VE TRIED WAY
OPPOSE SB- I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE A- THANK YOU NEXT PERCENT.
MEXICO LINE THREE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES STEVEN IN
MERION CDO NORTH COUNTY CLIMATE
CHANGE ALLIANCE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU NEXT. WITH RESPECT TO
THE LINE THREE OH THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI JOSE TRINIDAD
CASTANEDA FROM CLIMATE ACTION
CAMPAIGN APART ORANGE COUNTY
AND SAN DIEGO WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE IT. MEXICO LINE ONE OH
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT ONE
OF FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. STONE
DON'T ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
ELECTRICAL LINES FIVE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DAVID KATZ FROM TAMARACK SOLAR
PRODUCTS- I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSITION IT'S GOING TO
DESTROY JOBS. THANK YOU. AND
NEXT OVER THE LINE TO SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE ARE BACK ON
BEHALF OF THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. MEXICO LINE FIVE
OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HELLO MY NAME IS RAFA
SONNENFELD I'M IN SANTA CRUZ
CALIFORNIA AND- I'M A MEMBER OF
THE ACCOUNT CALIFORNIA'S
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ENVIRONMENTAL
CAUCUS AND OPPOSED TO THE BILL
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE THANK YOU.
AND NEXT THING ON THE LINE.
THREE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS KEEP COULD
SOLVE CRIME ONCE INTEGRITY
SOLAR AND SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA
AND I JUST WANNA SAY THAT I'M
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED TO THIS
HORRIBLE NO. THANK YOU. HE
ACTUALLY GOT A LINE TO FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JUST TO HIRE
POLITICAL COMBAT LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND WE HAVE AN OPPOSED IT
BUT UNLESS AMENDED POSITION FOR
THE REASONS OUTLINED OUR WATER
THANK YOU. AND ACTUALLY GOT A
LINE ONE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JIM ELROD ON
THE BUSINESS MANAGER FINANCIAL
SECRETARY OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS LOCAL FORTY MAKE
REPRESENTING KERN COUNTY ON
BEHALF OF THE OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED MEMBERS WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU. MEXICO
ALAINA FOUR OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE. FOUR OH FIVE.
HELLO MY NAME IS STACY RIGHT
NOW I AM WITH POWER TREAT
SERVICES SPECIALIZING IN SOLAR
OR- MULTI FAMILY RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES AND LOW INCOME
PROPERTY. AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
WILL HAVE A DISASTROUS IMPACT
SYSTEM YOUR NAME. AT R. IN
OPPOSITION. AB ONE ONE READ
NEXT PERSON. MEXICO LINE. FOUR
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
FOUR FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS FOR ME
PARTLY- WITH CLEAN FINANCING
ASSOCIATION OF FUNDERS
REPRESENTING FIVE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS OF FINANCING
FOR CAN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. UNLESS
YOU GET A LINE FOR THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
JACKIE ELLIOTT WITH SOLAR
MOTION AND- FELLOW THE BEST
CELL COUNTY THEN- THEN LOOKED
AT THE COUNTY MARIN COUNTY AND-
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MEXICO TO LINE THREE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
ARLENE BAXTER ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND MY HUSBAND WE ARE
EAST BAY RESIDENTS AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. MEXICO
LINE FOR FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SYLVIA
FERRARI ON BEHALF OF SUNPOWER
CORPORATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. IN MEXICO LINE ONE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH WE'RE JUST YOU KNOW WITH A
ONE SON AND BERKELEY STRONGLY
OPPOSE BILL WOULD DESTROY A
ONCE ON MOM AND POP SOLAR
COMPANIES BROUGHT. THIS IS.
NEXT PERCENT. ZERO ONE TWO
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HEY ON KERN FROM HOT PURPLE
ENERGY OUT OF THE COACHELLA
VALLEY AS IT WOULD DESTROY THE
JOB WITHOUT YOUR POSITION BY-
COACHELLA VALLEY RESIDENTS WE
STRONGLY. THE LECTURE LINE ONE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN HALL
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE KERN
COUNTY ELECTRICAL
APPRENTICESHIP AND TRAINING
TRUCK IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. NEXT TO THE LINE FOR
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. DUNCAN
CLEMENTS ARE REPRESENTING SOLAR
MANUFACTURER GAF ENERGY IN SAN
JOSE AND SANTA FELT STRONGLY
OPPOSE. MEXICO LINE THREE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAPSULAR CUSTOMER PASTORALIST
CALIFORNIA I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO AB ELEVEN THIRTY
NINE. ACTUALLY GOT A LINE THREE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
THE MAILING WHAT HOMICIDE OR DO
SERVING LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE. IN MEXICO LINE FOR
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY APOLOGIES ONE TO TEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE TO TEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. OKAY WE'LL TRY TO GO
BACK TO LINE FOR TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND BARBARA
STEPHENSON RETIRED SCHOOL
TEACHER ON A FIXED INCOME WHICH
WITH TOP SELLERS STRONGLY
OPPOSED. NEXT. ONE ONE TWO ONE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS JOHN I WILL AND WITHOUT
COME BY THEIR A SINGLE THAT SO
WE ARE SO OPPOSED YOU ELEVEN
NINE KILLER GOT THANK YOU. IN
MEXICO LINE THREE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO. YES THIS IS RICK FOREVER
WITH YOU K. B. AND WILL SOLVE
THE SOLAR AND ON BEHALF OF THE
OF AND KIND OF THAT ONE NINETY
PRESERVE GROUP ACROSS THE STATE
TO MENTION OUR HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES I SHOULD OPPOSE. JUST
AND LINE TO SIX. WE'VE GOT. I'M
WAS SOMEHOW SOLAR AND SENT AND
ICE AT AB FOR NINE BECAUSE THAT
KILL THE FULLER AND THANK YOU.
AND NEXT TO GO TO LAW THREE FOR
PLAY GO AHEAD. MY IS JOHN LACKS
HERE INSTEAD PAULA CALIFORNIA
WHERE MANY OF MY CUSTOMERS ARE
LOW INCOME- CUSTOMERS I WORK
FOR SON RUN I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO AB. ONE ONE THREE
NINE. THE NEXT WITH A LINE OF
THREE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MILLION MARKET BUT THE
CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY
CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO AT.
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. AND NEXT TO
THE LINE FOR EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS CLAIRE
BROOME REPRESENTING THE
NINETEEN THOUSAND RATEPAYERS
AND- THREE FIFTY BAY AREA.
UNTIL THE TRANSMISSION PROFITS
ARE INCREASING OUR RATES WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE THANK. YOU FOR.
NEXTERA THREE THIRTY FOR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DOMINO'S MORE STUCK
FOR. CHILDREN'S FOR SECOND
MODESTO USE DISTRICT STRONGLY
OPPOSES CA BILL. NEXT WE GOT
LINE TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS RYAN MONTGOMERY WITH SO
BROTHER DENNIS THE BEST STRONG
WE HAVE AS A KILL MY. LEVINE
THREE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS CHILDHOOD
SAN DIEGO GREEN NEW DEAL
ALLIANCE STRONGLY OPPOSE. WE GO
TO ONE THREE THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS JOYCE LANE
AND I'M WITH SAN DIEGO THREE
FIFTY AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AT.
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. THE NEXT TO
GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND. ONE
THIRTY TWO. OKAY AND WE'LL MOVE
ON TO LINE TO TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHERYL I AM WITH JUST THE
DEFICIT EQUITY DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION GROUP WITH THE
MECHANIC OF CRANIAL ALONG GREEN
NEW DEAL ONLINE. WHICH WRONGLY
OPPOSED AB THIRTY NINE THAT HER
LOAN AND MULTI FAMILY CUSTOMER
IN YOU. IT MAKES ONE TWO NOW.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR ONE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF PAY FOR
GROUP YOU CAN TELL THE COUNTRY
TO COUNTRY JUST OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANKS ALIGN FOR. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE ONE FIFTEEN. IT
MAY. THE RARE. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES- I DIDN'T REMEMBER THAT
THIS IS JENNIFER TANNER
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA REGION
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. TURN
OVER THE LINE THREE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SEAN YOU MEANT FROM
CALIFORNIA SOLAR INTEGRATOR ON
BEHALF OF OUR EIGHTY EMPLOYEES
AND THOUSANDS OF LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE A.
B. ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. PLUS A
LITTLE ONE THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK
HERREMANS BUSINESS MANAGER OF
IBEW LOCAL UNION FOUR SIXTY
FIVE ME AND MY TWO THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED UNION MEMBERS
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT. ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE. AN EXTRA LINE TO
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS KAREN HAMMOND HUMAN
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL AS WRITTEN A
SENT A CORRECTION TO THE STOCK
REPORT WHICH FAILED TO ADDRESS
THE NINETEEN NINETY FOR EXAMPLE
OR THE NET BENEFIT TALK AGAIN
PLEASE USE YOUR NAME AND
POSITION. THAT'S GOING TO FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
FORTY EIGHT. OKAY IT WILL MOVE
ON TO LINE. ONE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY IN ORDER
TO BRING THE POWER STRUGGLE
POSTED AT ELEVEN THIRTY NINE.
ACCORDING TO THE LINE THREE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JOHN DORY ON BEHALF OF SUNLAND
SOLAR IN OPPOSITION. AND NEXT
TO A LINE THREE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
MARGARET MILLER ON BEHALF OF NG
NORTH AMERICA IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. AND ACTUALLY GOT A
LINE TO THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JAMES
MYRON I'M WITH THE SANTA CRUZ
CLIMATE ACTION NETWORK WITH
SIXTEEN HUNDRED LOCAL
SUPPORTERS. WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE NAM PORTION OF AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE AND CALL ON IT HI
B. E. W. TO COME TO THEIR
SENSES IT'S PERSON PORTRAITIST
REPEATED. AND WE GO TO LINE TWO
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DAN MARTIN M. SOLUTIONS INC
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS MISGUIDED
BILL. AND ACTION DECLINED TO
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF HOT
PURPLE ENERGY IN PALM SPRINGS
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. WE GOT ONE
ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON GRETCHEN
NEWSOM ON BEHALF OF IBEW LOCAL
FIVE SIX NINE IN OUR THIRTY SIX
HUNDRED UNION ELECTRICIANS
ACROSS SAN DIEGO AND IMPERIAL
COUNTY STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. YES GOOD
POINT FOUR OH ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO IT GUARDSMEN AND
RESPOND FOR MYSELF I OPPOSE
BEEN BANNED BOOKS IN THIS BILL
THAT I SUPPORT AT PREVAILING
WAGE WORKING. THANK YOU. WE GO
TO ONE HUNDRED NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS JULIE
MILLER I AM A TAKES INCOME
APPROVED TOP SOLAR OWNER AND I
LIVE IN SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL WHICH IS BASED
ON YOUR OWN DELIGHT. THANK YOU.
MEXICO LINE THREE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JEFF POWER HOME THE OWNER OF A
SOLAR INSTALLER CULTS OR
TECHNOLOGIES IN THE BAY AREA
WITH EIGHTY EMPLOYEES AND FIVE
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE BECAUSE IT WOULD SHUT
DOWN OUR BUSINESS FIREARMS. OUR
CUSTOMERS. LINE FOUR FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS MARK
RODRIGUEZ FOR FUN RUN AYE
OPPOSED ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU. ONE TO NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS JASPER
WAS OLD IN SOLAR POWER IBEW
CONTRACTOR AND I OPPOSE
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE ONE THREE
NINE THANK YOU. AND ACTUALLY
GOT A LINE TO TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TOM ROSTON
CUSTOM POWER SOLAR STRONGLY
OPPOSE. ONE ONE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
WE'LL MOVE ON THE LINE TO SIXTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND BRING
THEM HERE CALLING FROM PAY OUR
REGION TEMPERANCE CISCO IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE. FIND ONE FIFTY
THREE SHE SAW HER. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS VINCENT
JOHNSON REPRESENTING COBALT
POWER SYSTEMS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION AB ONE ONE THREE
NINE THANK YOU. EACH LINE FOR
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
FOUR TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY THE TRY LINE. HI MY NAME
IS THEIR WALLS AND I WORK FOR
SUN RENDON DAN DIEGO I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
UNDERMINES THE STATE BUT THE
PENDULUM MANAGEMENT PROGRAM AND
IT'S IN THE BACK BOB BUT. NEXT
YOU'LL WANT TO FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI IS SUSAN
INTERNALLY THIS OCTOBER CAL AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL AND
YOU. WE GOT ALL TO- PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS RAY WINNIE
DOES C. WE BE PAYING NORMAL
ENERGY CONSULT IN MACULA. AND
WE STE MARIO A LOT OF. NINE SHE
GOT A LINE FOR FORTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
SCOTT SKINNER WITH A COMMERCIAL
SOLAR- CONTRACTOR IN THE
SILICON VALLEY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE A. B. ELEVEN THIRTY NINE.
MEXICO I TO FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHEVROLET
WEBER MY ROUTE SOLAR IN COME
AND FOR MORE THAN TWELVE THE
WE'RE- OUTSIDE IT AND STE A THE
ONE THIRTY NINE. ELEVEN THIRTY
NINE. AND WE GOT LINE FOR THIRD
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JERRY BROWN I WORK FOR CUBIC
ENERGY AND LIVE IN BUY SELL YOU
CALIFORNIA I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED AB ONE ONE THREE THIS
BILL WOULD CALL- KILLED THANK.
JOHNSON MAKE UP. NEXT TO THE
LINE THREE OH ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME IS MARK
STYLE WITH THE PAUL RENNER
GAZING BACK BILL CALIFORNIAN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. AND WE
GO TO LINE TWO THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
KEITH POSTER GRANT CLEANTECH
ENERGY SOLUTIONS STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU ONE
EIGHTY FOUR OKAY AND WE GOT A
LINE TO THIRTY SEVEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY ONE ONE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KAREN POSTER
WITH CLEANTECH ENERGY SOLUTIONS
IN OCEANSIDE CALIFORNIA YOU'RE
STRONG YOU SUPPOSE THIS BILL.
WE GO TO LINE TWO OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE SHE NEEDS I REPRESENT
MYSELF AND MY FAMILY I'M A
HOMEOWNER WITH A ROOFTOP SOLAR
AND I OPPOSE AB. ONE ONE THREE
NINE. AND WE GOT A LINE TO
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
MY NAME IS MADE BY HAND COCKRUM
RETIRED I'M A RESIDENT OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND A RETIRED
ELECTRICIAN AND MY SUPPORT AB
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. ACTUALLY
GOT A LINE ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M OUTRAGE
FROM ACR SOLAR NATIONAL IN
CARMICHAEL CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE WHICH IS ANTI JOBS
ANTI CONSUMER. AND NEXT WE GO
TO LINE THREE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS TYLER
POSHARD WITH SOME POWER IN
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN THIRTY
NINE. AND THEN WE GO TO LINE
ONE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS TIM LAKE MEN
FROM- EL SERENO IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY REPRESENTING THE
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS OF THE
GREEN PARTY CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. AND WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AT. ELEVEN THIRTY
NINE. TO GET A LINE OF ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS RICK THOMPSON
I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO AND I'M A MEMBER OF
THE INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD
OF ELECTRICAL WORKERS I'M
CALLING TO VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. WELL ONE TO THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORE AUNT
ON BEHALF OF. CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EACH ELECT.
THIRTY NINE. WE'LL GO TO LINE
FOR SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS JONATHAN COSTS ARE
RECENTLY BOUGHT A HOME WITH YOU
ROOFTOP SOLAR IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. ONE FOUR
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE THIS WILL
KILL THOUSANDS OF JOBS. IN ONE
THREE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SH KEVIN IN LOS ANGELES
ON THE SOLAR INSTALLER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. ELEVEN THIRTY
NINE. CAN WE GO TO LINE THREE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- THIS IS RALPH DENNIS
REPRESENTING AT THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA. ACTION WILLIAM WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED AS
OUTLINED IN THE LETTER
SUBMITTED BY SOLAR LIGHTS
ALLIANCES BY MEN CALIFORNIANS
ON APRIL SEVENTH. THANK YOU. WE
GOT A LINE TO FIFTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK CENTER I WORK
FOR CUBIC'S ENERGY WE'RE
STRONGLY OPPOSED AB. ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE. WE DON'T ALIGN ONE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PROXIMAL IBEW NUMBER OUT OF
FRESNO SCANDAL STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB WALL AGREE NOT. WE GOT A
LINE TO THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD- GOOD AFTERNOON FAMILY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOE PICKETT
I AM A BUSINESS AGENT AND
DISPATCHER FOR I. B. E. W.
LOCAL ONE EIGHTY. REPRESENTING
NAPA SOLANO COUNTY AND WE
SUPPORT AB ONE ONE THREE NINE
THANK YOU. ONE TWO FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
DESTRUCTIVE OWN OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA I WORK WITH
ALTERNATE ENERGY SYSTEMS AND I
AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. LINE FOR SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH ARE ALL MILLER
CLIMATE HAWKS VOTE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S
ENVIRONMENTAL CAUCUS CHAIR IN
THE MOVE TOP STORE OWNER IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU. I
WOULD GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
SEVEN. I'M SORRY YOUR LINE FOR
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY LET'S TRY ONE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME IS
STEVE BACK IN A REPRESENT
MYSELF AND PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
WAS SOLAR HAVE INVESTED A LOT
OF MONEY IN THEIR SOLAR ROOFTOP
SYSTEMS ASSUMING THAT. COULD
LEAD TO SOME OF. IN THIS BILL
TAKES THAT AWAY AND ONLY. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A- IT WOULD
ALIGN TO SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND TO SEVENTEEN. THIS
IS PETER STERN FROM ONE EIGHTY
SOLAR POWER I REPRESENT ALL OF
OUR EMPLOYEES AND THOUSANDS OF
CUSTOMERS AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. NINE FOUR FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S JOHN
SENDING SEN I'M A SOLAR
CONSUMER HOMEOWNER AS WELL AS
ON A RECRUITING BUSINESS PEAK
DEMAND OF SPECIALIZING IN THE
MARKET STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL ELEVEN THIRTY NINE IS IT
WILL DECIMATE THE INDUSTRY. ONE
FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS P.
SEVEN FROM CARDIFF BY THE SEA
CALIFORNIA I REPRESENT CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT I AM AN
ENVIRONMENTAL SPEAKER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THIS BILL
THANK YOU.PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ROY
JOHNSON- RESIDENT ESCONDIDO
CALIFORNIA AND I DO OPPOSE AB
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE THANK YOU.
AND ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS BILL
BAKER REPRESENTING ELECTRICAL
WORKERS IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE. LINE TWO FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWO FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO
STILL THERE. YEAH. MODERATOR
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN GIVEN HAVEN'T
BEEN GIVEN A NUMBER ONE FOR
THREE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS ERICA
MORGAN THAT'S FINE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR COMMUNITY ENERGY
IF STATEWIDE NETWORK OF
COMMUNITY ENERGY ADVOCATES AND
WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO IT.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE MODERATOR
THANK YOU MODERATOR WE HAVE
EXPIRED OUR TIME. I DO WANNA
REMIND FOLKS THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING THAT IN TESTIMONY TO
THE POSITION THAT OUR PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO NEED TO
VACATE THIS AND WEBER THIRTY
SEVEN HAVE TO MOVE ON. THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE HAS CALLED IN-
MEMBERS DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
MISS BURKE- FIRST I WANT TO
START BY AT LEAST A POINT
ACKNOWLEDGING AND APPRECIATING
THAT THE OPPOSITION ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE ARE INEQUITIES IN
THE SYSTEM AND IN THE PROGRAM I
THINK THAT'S A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BUT I DO WANT
TO STAY IN NO WAY DOES THIS
BILL KILL THE SOLAR INDUSTRY.
AND IF THE ONLY WAY THE SOLAR
INDUSTRY CAN EXIST IS ON THE
BACK OF LOW INCOME COMMUTERS I
WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE THAT THE
OPPOSITION THAT HAVE CALLED IN
WOULD BE CALLING IN WITH A MUCH
DIFFERENT ATTITUDE. I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR I KNOW THAT
CHALLENGING RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
INEQUITIES. IN ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICY IS REALLY HARD AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING ON THAT CHALLENGE- YOU
KNOW REBELLING. EVALUATING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE PROGRAMS
IS LONG OVERDUE AND THE ISSUE
OF COST SHIFTING IS AN
IMPORTANT ONE AND I'M A
BELIEVER THAT. EQUITY ON ALL
LEVELS OF OUR AND FIRE BERMAN A
POLICY IS VITAL FOR ALL
COMMUNITIES TO TRULY
PARTICIPATE AT. TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE- I HAVE LEGISLATION
THAT CALLED ATTENTION AND TRY
TO MAKE RIGHT FROM IN EQUITIES
IN THE COMMUNITY AND MY
DISTRICT IN THE DISTRICT OF THE
AUTHOR FACES AS WELL BECAUSE
FAR TOO OFTEN. THEY ARE AN
AFTERTHOUGHT IF THOUGHT OF AT
ALL. SO I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS BILL AND- I WILL BE VOTING
I THINK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
KING. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
I AM A PROUD- SORT HAD BEEN THE
SOLE SUPPORTER FOR YEARS AND
YEARS BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR WORKING ON THIS ISSUE I
THINK IT IS TIME THAT WE TAKE A
LOOK AT HOW WE PAY FOR THE
OVERALL SYSTEM- HOW THOSE COSTS
ARE DIVIDED I THINK THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PIECES OF THEBILL
THAT I PROBABLY SUPPORT
ESPECIALLY. ON THE ON
PREVAILING WAGE PART OF THE
BILL I DID HAVE SOME CONCERNS I
KNOW THAT MY OF MY OFFICE TO
CALL YOUR OFFICE ABOUT WAS. THE
AMOUNT OF TIME- FERDINAND
CUSTOMERS AFTER THEY WERE
INSTALLED TO. RECOUP SOME OF
THEIR COST I KNOW THAT I WAS AN
EARLY ADOPTER. OF SOLAR AND
REALLY DID RELY ON THEM TO.
HELP RECOUP THAT SOMEONE. YOU
ARE THE AUTHOR WOULD CONSIDER
GOING FROM FIVE YEARS TO TEN
YEARS THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
WOULD BE. DISTANCING ALSO KNOW
THAT- IN A VERY LATE VERSION OF
THE BILL. THERE WAS A THERE WAS
LANGUAGE THAT WAS STRUCK. YEAH
I KNOW THE INDUSTRY AT THE
STORE SHE'S VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT. THAT STRUCK THE PART
THAT SAYS CUSTOMER SIDE TO
RENEWABLE ENERGY MUST GROW
SUSTAINABLY. AND I'M HOPING
THAT THE AUTHOR COULD WORK-
WHAT THE SOLAR INDUSTRY TO
REALLY FIVE- LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD BE MORE ACCEPTED ONE OF
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY
REALLY- FIELD IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO THEM. AND I THINK IF YOU
WERE WILLING TO WORK ON THOSE
TWO PROVISIONS I THINK THIS IS
A BILL THAT I COULD. SUPPORT TO
GET OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY-
WITH- THE IDEA THAT I HAVE TO
TAKE A LOOK ON THE FLOOR TO SEE
WHAT IT WOULD. LOOK LIKE
WITHOUT THE FOR. AND I AM
HOPEFUL ARE ARE I. DID YOU BACK
TO YOU. WILL WORK ON BOTH OF
THOSE THINGS I HAVE THAT. NO
REAL CONCERNS EXTENDING IT TO
TEN YEARS FOR BOTH KAREN ON
HERE- AT CUSTOMERS I DO
UNDERSTAND I'M ALSO SOLAR AT.
CUSTOMER IN FACT MY CONTRACTOR
CALLED TWICE IT SOUNDED LIKE-
ID ARE UTILIZED IBEW WORKERS
FOR ROOFTOP SOLAR. THERE'S ONE
COMPANY AND THEY AT. IN SAN
DIEGO AND I DID DO EXTENSIVE
RESEARCH ON HOW LONG IT WOULD
TAKE BACK WE WILL GET OUR MONEY
BACK EVEN USING. UNION
INSTALLERS BUT BEFORE THE TEN
YEARS AND SO I JUST I
APPRECIATE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS BUT THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO REALLY START
PUSHING. THANK YOU. THIS
CARILLO. COULD CAN HEAR MY FOR
GO I'M I HAVE A QUESTION I
WONDER IF MR JONATHAN SCOTT IS
STILL THE INITIAL WITNESS IS
STILL ON THE LINE. MODERATOR.
THIS IS KIND OF A LEVEL.
WHENEVER WE LOOKING FOR I DID
CATCH IT. WE'RE LOOKING FOR
MISTER JONATHAN SCOTT ONE OF
THE ORIGINAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WHAT IF YOU DEVELOP
A ONE MOMENT PLEASE. YOUR
STRATEGY TO ON THE CALL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO OPEN UP
YOUR LINE. I DON'T WANT TO CALL
ANYMORE. THANK YOU FOR THAT- IF
FOR THOSE OF HIS I GET THE
GROUP THAT HE'S CALLING ON
BEHALF FROM I'M JUST CURIOUS IF
HE'S A PAID SPOKESPERSON FOR
SON RUNS FOR SON RAN SUN RUN
AND IF HE'S ALSO A LICENSED
CONTRACTOR IN CALIFORNIA
CONSIDERING HIS COMMENTS ON OUR
STATE. LET ME CONTINUE ON WITH
MY COMMENTS I- I WROTE AN
ORIGINAL BILL- RELATED TO NET
ENERGY MEETING LAST YEAR WHICH
WE HELD ECAUSE OF COLD IT AND
HAVE BEEN JUST COMPLETELY
STRUCK BY THE FACT THAT THIS AT
THE NET ENERGY METERING HAS NOT
BEEN RESTRUCTURED. UP FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW GIVEN THAT
THE CALIFORNIA PC HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO AND HAS
NOT DONE SO- THIS BILL DOES NOT
KILL SOLAR ENERGY THAT'S A
COMPLETE FALSEHOOD- AND I WOULD
SAY THAT NOW MORE THAN EVER
POLICYMAKERS AND REGULATORS
ALIKE HAVE AN OBLIGATION. TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE PURSUING OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS
AND TRANSITIONING 21100% CLEAN
ENERGY IN A MATTER THAT
ACHIEVES A MAXIMUM BENEFIT OF
THE LEASE AND THE LEASE
POSSIBLE COSTS FOR CUSTOMERS
THE CURRENT STRUCTURE FOR NAM
FAILS TO ACHIEVE THAT OBJECTIVE
BECAUSE IT MANDATES THAT
UTILITIES PURCHASE EXCESS POWER
GENERATED FROM ROOFTOP SYSTEMS
THAT ARE. AT A RATE ROUGHLY
FIVE TIMES HIGHER THAN A CAN BE
PURCHASED ANOTHER SOURCES
EVERYBODY BENEFITS FROM OF THE
ENERGY GRID AND EVERYBODY
SHOULD PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE AND
THAT'S NOT CURRENTLY THE
REALITY AND THAT'S NOT THE
REALITY OF EQUITY IN ENERGY A
STRONG RELIABLE ELECTRICAL GRID
IS CRITICAL TO ALL ELECTRICITY
CUSTOMERS ALSO HAVE. SOLAR AT
HOME AND THOSE WHO DON'T AND
HOWEVER THE CURRENT AD
TERRIBLE L. SOLAR CUSTOMERS TO
BY PASS THESE MAINTENANCE COSTS
IN ADDITION TO A PORTION OF
PUBLIC PURPOSES PROGRAMS COST
NAM TERRORISTS SHOULD NOT BE
REGRESSIVE AND EXCESSIVE IN
COMPARISON TO OTHER POLICY
MANDATES THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
ANNUAL NAMM KASHIF NOW EXCEEDS
THAT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE RATE FOR
ELECTRICITY WHICH IS THE CARE
PROGRAM. WHICH IS A SUBSIDY AT
ABOUT A COST OF ONE BILLION AND
IT HELPS. TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION VULNERABLE OWING SOME
CUSTOMERS OF THE STATE.
MEANWHILE JUST ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS RECEIVE SUBSIDIES FOR
THEIR SOLAR SYSTEMS AND YET ARE
RESPONSIBLE. FOR RAISING THE
ENERGY RATES TO LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME CALIFORNIANS AT A COST
OF ABOUT TWO BILLION ANNUALLY.
THIS IS NOT A FORMULA BASED ON
EQUITY NOR SHOULD IT BE A
FORMULA AS PRAISED AS THE
ANSWER TO THE FUTURE OF OUR
STATE. ALL CALIFORNIANS SHOULD
CONTRIBUTE EQUITABLY TOWARDS
THE STATE'S CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
AND CERTAINLY OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. SHOULD
NOT BE EXPECTED TO CARRY THE
LOAD FOR THOSE. WITH HIGHER
INCOMES CLEAN ENERGY
INVESTMENTS TO MEET
CALIFORNIA'S 1100% CLEAN POWER
GOAL SHOULD BE BALANCED.
CUSTOMER CHOICES AND THAT THEY
SHOULD BE EQUITABLE. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT OUR STATE CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS AND CUSTOMERS CONTINUED
ABILITY TO CHOOSE TO INSTALL
SOLAR HOWEVER. NOT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE OPTION OF
GENERATING OR STORING THEIR OWN
CLEAN POWER. A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT WHO OWNS THEIR HOME.
AND HAS THE LUXURY OF
INSTALLING SOLAR SHOULD NOT BE
SUBSIDIZED BY A RENTER WHO
DOESN'T OWN THE ROOF OF THEIR
HOME. AND HAS TO MAKE UP FOR
THE COST. OF OUR MUCH NEEDED
ENERGY GRID. THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSIONS
HAD AND HAS SQUANDERED THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES AND ADJUSTING.
NET ENERGY METERING ON THE
BACKS OF WORKING CLASS
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR LACK OF
ACTION HAS CREATED A FALSE
NARRATIVE. WHICH WE HEARD
THROUGHOUT THE TESTIMONY. AND
THE WITNESSES CALLING IN. SO
THE CHOICE OF ONE CUSTOMER TO
INSTALL ROOFTOP SOLAR SHOULD
NOT CONTINUE. TO RESULT IN AN
INCREASE OF THE ELECTRICAL
BILLS TO CUSTOMERS WHO DON'T
HAVE THIS CHOICE. FOR THOSE.
THAT BELIEVE IN. THE PILLARS OF
THE GREEN NEW DEAL THOSE
PILLARS INCLUDE A JUST
TRANSITION OF WORKERS. IT
INCLUDES CALLING OUT FOR GOOD
QUALITY WELL PAID SECURE JOBS
GOOD UNION JOBS. FOCUSING ON
AREAS IN COMMUNITIES WHERE
THERE ARE NEEDED. THE MOST IT
SEEKS TO DRAW ON THE SKILLS AND
POTENTIAL OF PEOPLE TO
TRANSFORM THE WAY THAT WE-
TRAVEL THE WAY THAT WE CREATE
ENERGY. THE WAY THAT WE PRODUCE
AND CONSUME ENERGY AND THE WAY
THAT WE MANAGE THE LAND THE WAY
WE GROW FOOD HOW WE EAT AND HOW
WE WORK WE ARE IN AN
INTERESTING TIME IN THE WE KEEP
TALKING. ABOUT IT JUST
TRANSITION AND DOING VERY
LITTLE TO ACTUALLY HELP WORKERS
ACHIEVE THAT. ADJUSTING THE NET
ENERGY METERING TO TODAY'S
REALITIES AND COSTS IS
ESSENTIAL. IN CALIFORNIA
ACHIEVING CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS
AND ULTIMATELY A DIVERSE ENERGY
PORTFOLIO WHICH WE- VERY MUCH
NEED I AM PROUD TO BE A JOINT
AUTHORS ON THIS BILL. I AM
HAPPY TO CONTINUE HAVING THE
CONVERSATIONS OF. THE ACTUAL
HONEST CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
THE FUTURE OF THIS INDUSTRY
LOOKS LIKE AND HOW WE ACTUALLY
TRULY. DO A JUST TRANSITION
THANK YOU. THANK A MISFIRE HERE
HERE THAT THAT THAT THAT
BECAUSE I ANSWERED THE QUESTION
POSED THIS IS BRAD HAD HER-
CALIFORNIA SOLAR STORAGE
ASSOCIATION AND THE PANELISTS
IN OPPOSITION AND TO ANSWER THE
FIRST QUESTION- JONATHAN SCOTT
IS NOT A PAID CONSULTANT AND
SPOKESPERSON OF SUN RUN AND. IS
NOT PAID BY ANYONE TO APPEAR
TODAY. THE SECOND QUESTION WAS
SIERRA A LICENSE CONTRACTOR IN
THE STATE. I DO NOT KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION. THANK
YOU MISTER ARCHAEON. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND- YOU KNOW I'VE
I'VE LEARNED A LOT JUST BY
READING ANALYSIS ON THIS BILL.
AND THEM IS COMPLICATED AND I
ALSO AM A ROOFTOP SOLAR
CUSTOMER. AB BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WAS MOST ARE DOING
TO ME IN READING THIS ANALYSIS
WITH THAT CHART. THEY LAID OUT
THE AMOUNT OF COST SHIFTING
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE PAST BUT
ALSO WHAT WE PROJECT TO SEE IN
THE FUTURE IN THE AMOUNT OF
GROWTH IN COST SHIFTING. AND I
DO REALLY WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR- UNDER EFFORTS ON THIS
BILL WHICH ARE. LARGEST NOT AN
EASY EFFORT- TO REALLY LOOK AT
THAT QUESTION BECAUSE WE SHOULD
BE CAUTIOUS THING BETWEEN
COMMUNITIES THEY COULD AFFORD
SOLAR. AND THOSE THEY CANNOT
OUR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES THEY
DON'T GET THE BENEFITS OF THIS
PROGRAM. AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT THE PC SHOULD HAVE ALREADY
DONE. YEAH AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE SAY THAT HERE
TODAY. THAT IS THE BODY WITH
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY OVER
THE P. YOU SEE THEY HAVE FAILED
TO DO WHAT THE AUTHOR IS TRYING
TO DO TODAY. AND I THINK IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON US TO URGE THEM
TO DO IT. AND TO DO IT RIGHT
THEY'RE THE ONES WITH THE
EXPERTISE. TO DO THIS IN A WAY
THAT MAKES SENSE. AND ONE OF MY
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL IS THAT
ALTHOUGH I ABSOLUTELY LOVED.
THE EFFORTS OF THE AUTHOR AND I
THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE ALREADY
READY AUTHOR WANTS US TO BE
WHICH IS NOT SHIFTING THOSE
COSTS. IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
ME THAT- I SHERM MISTER TINGS.
CONCERNS ABOUT THE STRIKING OF
ENSURING. THAT CUSTOMER SITED
RENEWABLES CONTINUES TO GROW
SUSTAINABLY AND I UNDERSTAND
WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM WITH
THAT. BUT AS SOMEONE WHO
REPRESENTS. A COMMUNITY WHERE
WE ACTUALLY HAVE AN AREA THAT
HAS SEEN A GROWTH IN SOLAR
FARMS IN SOME OF THE LARGER.
SOLAR INSTALLATIONS IT'S HARD
TO GET THOSE DONE. THE
PERMITTING IT'S HARD IT HAS TO
BE NEAR. CONNECTIONS TO
UTILITIES IN ORDER FOR IT TO
PAN OUT WHICH ISN'T ALWAYS
TRUE. THERE'S A LOT OF FIGHTS
LIKE THE ONE WE SAW TODAY WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY NOT
WHEN YOU SEE THAT OPEN SPACE
TURNED INTO A SOLAR FARM. AND
IT WAS A RESULT OF ALL OF THAT.
I THINK THAT ROOFTOP SOLAR HAVE
TO BE A PART OF. OUR ANSWER TO
GETTING TO A 1100% CLEAN FUTURE
WHICH I KNOW THE AUTHOR AGREES
WITH I KNOW SHE DOES NOT INTEND
TO KILL ROOFTOP SOLAR NOR DOES.
SHE BELIEVE THIS. THIS SAID SHE
IS THAT BUT I DO THINK WE NEED
A BALANCE BETWEEN. ELIMINATING
THE COST SHIFTING WHICH IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND ENSURING THAT
WE ARE. INCENTIVIZING SOLAR
SUIT ROOFTOP SOLAR SO CONTINUES
TO GROW. AND I'M SORRY TO SEE
THE PARTS OF THE BILL THAT
INCENTIVIZE DID ESPECIALLY OUR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES REMOVED
I THOUGHT THAT WAS. A WONDERFUL
EFFORT EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY WHICH
IS INCENTIVIZING. SOLAR SO I
REALLY HOPE THAT WE GET TO A.
PLACE WHERE THE P. C. DOES THIS.
AND CHANGES THE DYNAMIC THAT IS
ON A- TO. AND DOES IT IN A THEY
CAN TO. SCHOOL THIS PART OF OUR
RENEWABLE FUTURE TO. GROW AND
THRIVE AND PROVIDE ENERGY IN
THE WAY THAT DOES TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SEEN NO FURTHER
COMMENTS FROM. MEMBERS I DO I
HAVE A MOTION. A MISSED I
APOLOGIZE MISTER MAYES. AS
MICROPHONE UP. THINK ABOUT
CHAIR SO I HAVE A LOTS OF
QUESTIONS BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE- THIS THE BILL CAME UP-
WAS SAVED GOD WELL IT WAS
GUTTED- AND THERE'S- THERE'S
NEW LANGUAGE I THINK- IN HERE-
AND- SO I'M AND I'M KIND OF
STRUGGLING FRANKLY. I WITH
WHERE I'M AT ON THIS BECAUSE I
DON'T LIKE THE COST OF EITHER-
FACT THAT IS IT IS NOT AN
OPINION IS A FACT- IT WAS A
POLICY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO SUBSIDIZE ROOFTOP SOLAR AT
THE BEGINNING. A WHEN IT WAS IN
ITS IN ITS INFANCY- IT IS NO
LONGER IN ITS INFANCY- WHY DO
WE KNOW THAT WE KNOW THAT
BECAUSE IT'S THREE BILLION
DOLLAR COST SHIFT AND WE JUST
HEARD ALL OF THEM THE SPECIAL
INTEREST GROUPS THAT HAVE
FORMED- A THIRD TO PROTECT AT
THIS PARTICULAR INDUSTRY AND OF
COURSE. THAT'S WHAT YOU DO WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUTTHREE
BILLION THREE BILLION DOLLARS
AT THE SAME TIME YOU KNOW I
REPRESENT A DESERT A COMMUNITY
WE HAVE AN AWFUL LOT OF ROOFTOP
SOLAR IN MY DISTRICT A LOT OF
ROOFTOP SOLAR AND IN THE
SUMMERTIME. WE DON'T HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF THAT SEA BREEZE I
FOR SOME OF THE COASTAL
COMMUNITIES AND YOU KNOW OUR
ELECTRIC BILLS AREN'T TWO
HUNDRED OR THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH THEY ARE EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH A
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH TWELVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH. AND
THIS SOLAR ENERGY IS- IS REALLY
SOMETHING THAT IS- IS SO
IMPORTANT JUST JUST FOR OUR
LOCAL ECONOMY AND SO I'M
STRUGGLING SORT OF BACK AND
FORTH ON WHAT TO DO WITH THIS
WHAT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO
BECAUSE I DO THINK THAT WE NEED
TO ACTUALLY HAVE A REAL.
CONVERSATION ABOUT IT SOMETHING
HAS TO BE DONE WE CAN'T
CONTINUE TO SUBSIDIZE- THIS-
THIS IS NOT A INTO INDUSTRY
LONG LONGER WE CAN'T CONTINUE
TO SUBSIDIZE IT SO IF I CAN'T
IF THERE'S SOMEBODY TO BE ABLE
TO ANSWER- MAYBE A FEW A FEW
QUESTIONS- ONE OF THEM- IS- ON
I'M LOOKING AT PAGE SEVEN OF
THE ANALYSIS WHERE IT TALKS
ABOUT NAM ONE. POINT OH- IN TWO
POINT OH- IT'S- THE LEGACY.
FROM ONE POINT OH TO POINT OH
THIS THREE POINT OH TERROR I
DON'T KNOW THAT MEANS SO THE
RATES THAT WERE PUT IN UNDER
NAB ONE POINT OH ARE STILL IN
EXISTENCE FOR THOSE- SOLAR
CUSTOMERS THEY PROBABLY REAP
THE BENEFITS BEYOND. IMAGINABLE
AND GOTTEN THEIR MONEY BACK ON
ON THE FULLER INSTITUTE TO. THE
NEXT REITERATION WITH NUMBER
TWO POINT NOW. THIS WOULD BE
NUMBER THREE POINT OH TO
RESTRUCTURE AGAIN THE RATES
THAT IT AND HOW ARE CALCULATING
THOSE RATES WHAT IT SAYS IS
THOSE EARLIER CUSTOMERS. THE
BILL NOW SAYS WILL EASE IN IN
THE AGREEMENT I MADE JUST A FEW
MINUTES GO WITH MISTER KING IS
OVER TEN YEARS THEY WILL EASE
INTO THESE NEW RATES SO. IF FOR
IT. AND I'M A PERFECT EXAMPLE
WE GOT SOLAR LAST YEAR- AND SO
WE WERE STRUCTURING OUR HE BACK
IF YOU WILL. BASED ON THE NAMM
TWO POINT OH RATES IT WOULD
ENSURE THAT I KEEP THOSE RATES
FOR TEN YEARS SO WOULD BE PAID
OFF- BEFORE YOU KNOW THE
BIGGEST SUBSIDY WOULD BE GONE.
THE PROBLEM IS ESPECIALLY WITH
THE NO ONE POINT OH CUSTOMERS
IS WE ARE OVER SUBSIDIZING.
WHICH WE DIDN'T JUST
INCENTIVIZE YOU KNOW THEY THEY
PAY BACK THEIR SYSTEM. IN THERE
NOT JUST GETTIN THEIR SAVINGS
OF SOLAR THEY'RE GETTING-
REALLY SUBSIDIZED ON THEIR
PAYMENT TO THE GREAT AND THAT'S
WHAT WE EVENTUALLY NEED TO GET
AWAY FROM. SO MAYBE THE ONE
OTHER WAY OF ASKING THIS
QUESTION IS IF YOU ARE PUTTING
ON A HUGE CAPITAL OUTLAY OUT
YOUR SPENDING 300-004-0000
WHATEVER THE AMOUNT IS. YOU
MAKE THAT DECISION BASED UPON A
PROMISE OR WHETHER THE CONTRACT
WITH ITS IMPLIED OR NOT- THAT.
IF I PUT THIS ON TODAY I AM
GOING TO GET THIS BENEFIT
COMING OUT ARE WE CHANGING-
THAT DEAL- OR OR WHERE WHERE
SEND SETTING OUT THAT DEAL SO
NOBODY WILL BE IN A SITUATION
WHERE IT DIDN'T MAKE. SENSE TO
GET THE SOLAR THAT THEY LOST
MONEY ON THE SOLAR WE'RE GOING
TO PRESERVE THEIR ABILITY TO
MAK MONEY ON THEIR SOLAR BUT
THEY'RE GOING TO QUIT MAKING AS
MUCH MONEY ON. THEIR SOLAR AT
TEN YEARS FROM NOW. BECAUSE
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN PAID BY. THE
SYSTEMS ARE BE PAID BACK IN AS
A THEY'RE MAKING MONEY. OFF OF-
OFF THE TOP THE GRID HAVING TO
BUY THEIR EXCESS SOLAR GET AND
THEN THE OTHER OF MAYBE ONE
OTHER QUESTION IF I CAN MADAM.
MADAM CHAIR IS- UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS IS THE FIRST HEARING
RIGHT THIS IS THE OF THE FIRST
YEAR TO TWO YEAR SESSION. AND
THERE ARE- BILLS THAT COME UP-
AND WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING A- REAL
CONVERSATION AND REAL
DISCUSSION. AND SOMETIMES THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TO DO THINGS.
TO MAKE OTHER AGENCIES- BEGIN
TO WORK ITS WAY UNDER. I
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT IS US
HAVING THIS BILL THIS VEHICLE
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE. SO THAT WE
CAN MAYBE FOR SOME OTHER AGENCY
LIKE THE P. YOU SEE- TO- TO DO
WHAT THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO DO.
SO THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO ME
HERE IS THAT THE WHOLE POINT OF
THE COMMISSION. IS IT FOR TO BE
NONPOLITICAL AND YET THEY FOUND
THERE'S A LOT OF THESE
COMMISSIONS. THAT ACTS A VERY
POLITICAL- AND IF THE POLITICAL
BODIES THE ONE IT'S ACTUALLY
HAVING TO COME INTO FORCE. IN
FORCES ACTUALLY UPSIDE THE
UPSIDE DOWN OR BACKWARDS.
THAT'S HOW IMPORTANT IS IT THAT
THIS OF THIS VEHICLE MOVES SO
IT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AND- I
THINK THAT IT WAS MADE EVEN
MORE STRIKINGLY IMPORTANT BY
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
BECAUSE IT. DOESN'T IF YOU SEE
ACCESS IT DOESN'T GO INTO
EFFECT THEY CAN MAKE A NEW.
RATE STRUCTURE- WE ARE JUST
SAYING IT'S TIME FOR THE PC TO
ACT IF YOU'RE NOT WILLING TO
ACT WILL LEGISLATE ON IT
OBVIOUSLY IT WOULD BE MORE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE PC TO ACT.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MANAGER. THANK YOU X. HONORING
MY MEMBERS WE HAVE OR BILL. AND
WE NEED VACATE BY FOUR THIRTY
BUT- THE DISCUSSION A IMPORT.
THIS WAY IF. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR EIGHT I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE COMES FROM
MISTER KING- MAYES- AND I
THINK. MOST OF THAT HAS BEEN
RESOLVED I THINK THAT. THE LAST
QUESTION FROM FROM- THE
GENTLEMAN FROM YOUR FIVE K. IS
THE IMPORTANCE OF CONTINUING
THIS CONVERSATION ALL RIGHT. I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND
FROM THE OPPOSITION I THINK
THOSE ARE NOT TAKEN LIGHTLY.
AND MAKING SURE THAT THE CUT
CONVERSATION CONTINUES AND THAT
THIS BILL. MOVES FORWARD AND IN
THE END YOU'RE RIGHT WE WANT TO
DO YOU SEE TO. DO THE WORK.
WE'RE ASKING THEM TO DO SO- I
FOR TODAY I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. RESERVE MY RIGHT TO
A DIFFERENCE WHEN IT COMES BACK
TO SEE EXACTLY WHAT'S HAPPENED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
BILL REMEMBERS BURKE SECOND
ALBUM IS CARILLO MR GARCIA A BE
BRIEF THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW WORDS
I. MY COLLEAGUE FROM
RESTAURANTS I THINK HE MOVED
FROM YUCAIPA YUCCA VALLEY NOW
TO FRENCH BRONZE. TWENTY
TERRIFIED THAT HE MAKES SOME
EXCELLENT POINTS. OUT WE SHARE
THE DESERT COMMUNITIES- ALIKE
AND THE SOLAR INDUSTRY
CERTAINLY HAS REACHED OUT TO US
AND SAID HEY THIS IS GOING TO
BE ONE. A JOCULAR MAYBE YOU CAN
BE ADDRESSED THAT POINT IN YOUR
CLOSING COMMENTS NUMBER TWO.
YOU KNOW- I SEE THIS AS US
PUSHING THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. TO DO THEIR JOB-
THE JOB THAT THEY'VE BEEN TAKEN
DOWN THE ROAD FOR QUITE SOME
TIME. AND THEN THE CORE OF THE
BILL TO THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE EAGLE ROCK
AREA- THIS IS ABOUT ADDRESSING
SOME INEQUITY- FORMULAS- THAT
HAS BEEN OVERBURDENING.
SUBPOPULATION FOR OTHERS TO
BENEFIT FROM GETTING SOLAR YOU
KNOW MAYBE IN YOUR CLOSING
COMMENTS YOU CAN ALSO SHARE
WITH US HOW THIS WILL BE
BECAUSE MY WHOLE PURPOSE IN
GOLDEN. ENGAGING INTO THE
CLIMATE SPACE. DISCUSSIONS IS
HOW DO WE HAVE POOR PEOPLE. THE
PART OF. THE BENEFITS OF OUR
PAUL ARE POOR PEOPLE GETS OLDER.
UNDER UNDER HOUSES HARDLY ARE
POOR PEOPLE IN E. V. VEHICLES
TO TRY TO ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE. AS ONE OF OUR FORMER
LEADERS THE SENATE USED TO SAY
THE MARKET TIES ARE CLIMATE
CHANGE POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR PURPOSES OF BRINGING
EVERYONE ALONG AND MAYBE YOU
CAN ADDRESS THOSE. IN YOUR
CLOSING COMMENTS AS IT RELATES
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU WILL
MOVE ON TO THE SERVER IS TO
CHANGE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATED THE AUTHORS THE
LAST COMMENT ABOUT THE-
AGREEMENT THAT IDEALLY THE PC
SHOULD BE ACTING ON THIS
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT THE
PC HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS
LENGTHY STAKEHOLDER. DRIVEN
PROCESS AND SO- I'M HOPING THAT
THE PC WILL DO THE JOB I MEAN.
AND CLEARLY- THIS BILL RACES-
IN ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN
STRUGGLING FOR A LONG TIME THIS
ISSUE OF COST SHIFTING-
OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT FAIR THAT-
THAT LOW INCOME PEOPLE ARE.
CARRYING THE BURDEN OF- OF- AND
THAT THE- THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO. INSTALL SOLAR- HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO AVOID IN TERMS OF
THE MANY OF THE COSTS- THAT-
THAT- THEY THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
AVOID- THIS IS BEEN A THIS IS A
DIFFICULT BILL FOR ME I MEAN ON
THE ONE HAND OBVIOUSLY I DON'T
TO- I WANT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
OF COST SHIFTING I WANT TO
SUPPORT. THE GOOD UNION JOBS-
THAT WOULD- GO TOWARD- THE-
BILL'S PROPOSAL ON THE OTHER
HAND I. I DON'T LIKE LOOKING AT
THE LETTERS I MEAN THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE- THE
CONCERNS- REYES ON THIS BILL
YOU KNOW FRANKLY DON'T SEEM TO
BE ADDRESSED. IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THE COMMITTEE NOW ALSO
STRUCK ME AS MORE OF AN
EDITORIAL THAT A- OBJECTIVE
ANALYSIS OF A- OF A MANY
DEDUCTIONS- REYES LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE I SEE THAT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IS IN
SUPPORT AND CONCEPT. SO DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE ALL OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS ARE IN
UNANIMITY IN OPPOSITION- AND SO
BOTTOM LINE ITEM I. WELL NOW BE
VOTING TODAY AND I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE HOW THIS BILL CONTINUES
TO DEVELOP THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE RIGHT I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER WORK ON THIS AND
FOR AGREEING TO THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS I WILL ASK HER FOR
HER CLOSING COMMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND- THE PC HAS HAD
THE MANDATE TO TAKE CARE OF
THIS FOR A WHILE AND THE THEY
THE MORE WE ASKED THE MORE GETS
PUSHED OFF- SO DOES BEAR. ON US
TO MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS I
LIVE IN A COMMUNITY QUITE
FRANKLY I LIVE A LIFE WHERE I
TRY TO BE GUILT FREE LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY THAT MOST PEOPLE
CANNOT AFFORD ROOFTOP SOLAR IT
EITHER BECAUSE THEY DON'T OWN
THEIR ACTUAL HOUSE THAT THEY'RE
LIVING IN OR IT'S JUST TOO
EXPENSIVE AN OUTLAY AND INSTEAD
THEY'RE BEARING THE BRUNT OF ME.
PUTTING SOLAR ON MY HOUSE.
THERE'S SOMETHING PERVERTED
ABOUT THAT AND SOMETHING THAT I
THINK IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
ADD A FAIRNESS TO. DO WE HAVE
TO FIND WAYS FOR WORKING CLASS
FOLKS AND POOR FOLKS TO HAVE.
TO BENEFIT AS AS MY COLLEAGUE
SAID FROM FROM THE GREEN
ECONOMY WE DO WE DO AND I TRIED
TO PUT SOME OF THAT INTO THE
BILL. THE COMMITTEE NOW SAYS
WANTED TO JUST DEAL WITH THIS
ISSUE WHICH I'M WILLING TO DO
AND COME BACK AND DEAL WITH
SOME OF THE INCENTIVES ON THE
OTHER. I DO THINK WE HAVE TO
GET WE WILL HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
INCENTIVIZE SOLAR- AND SOME
POINTS FOR SOME CUSTOMERS FOR A
VERY LONG TIME. THAT IS THAT IS
A PROGRAM WE SHOULD BE WORKING
ON AS WELL. BUT IT IS NOT-
EQUITABLE IT IS NOT FAIR- TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE. FOR EXAMPLE
AND THE GERMANFROM NO LONGER
FROM YUCAIPA PREVIOUSLY FROM
YUCAIPA. WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE
THOSE SUMMERTIME BILLS THINK
ABOUT THIS THE SUMMERTIME BILLS
WHEN YOU CAN'T AFFORD SOLAR.
AND IT'S TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
A MONTH. IN RISING BECAUSE MORE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING SOLAR AND
SHIFTING THOSE COSTS TO YOU
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG THERE.
AND SO IT IS UP TO US TO TRY TO
CORRECT IT. DESPITE SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION'S COMMENTS I DON'T
THINK ANYONE HERE HATE SOLAR
NOBODY'S GOING TO KILL SOLAR WE
HAVE A SOLAR MANDATE ON NEW
CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSES. THAT IT
IS IT IS- TERROR LANGUAGE LIKE
THAT THAT IS SCARING PEOPLE OUT
OF COMMONSENSE REFORMS THAT CAN
BENEFIT ENTIRE COMMUNITIES. AND
QUITE FRANKLY SOMEBODY WHO.
CONSIDERS HERSELF A MEMBER OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY IT
IS DISHEARTENING.TO SEE THE
DISMISSAL OF THE COST SHIFTING
ISSUE. BY THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT THAT I FEEL STRONGLY
ENOUGH TO TAKE THE CRITICISM.
FROM FOR HIM THE OPPONENTS TO
TRY TO DEAL WITH. THAT THERE'S
PROBABLY. JUST THE PRICE OF
LIVING IT IS PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST ISSUE IN MY DISTRICT
AND I KNOW SOME OF YOU HAVE THE
SAME TYPE JUST. TRYING TO GET
BY YOUR ELECTRICITY BILL. SO WE
HAVE TO DO SOMETHING. IT WON'T
MAKE ME THE MOST POPULAR
ENVIRONMENTALISTS THE STATE
WHAT WE TRY TO DO IT I'M OKAY
WITH THAT BUT I DO APPRECIATE
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE STRETCHING
AND WILLING TO LET THIS
CONVERSATION MOVE. SO THAT WE
CAN PUSH THE P. YOU SEE
HOPEFULLY TO DO THEIR JOB. AT
PREVAILING WAGE DISTILLER WHICH
SHOULD HAVE BEEN THERE ALL
ALONG AND FINALLY GET THEM
RIGHT. SO WITH THAT RESPECT
LAST NIGHT ABOUT. THANK YOU THE
MOST IN A TO PASS OF THE MEN
TO. SIX SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CRISTINA GARCIA
HI CRISTINA GARCIA I'D
PATTERSON. PATTERSON AYE
BARRICADE HAND. BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO CARILLO I'D CHAO CHAO I
CHEN CHEN I'D CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING EDUARDO
GARCIA. MAYES MURATSUCHI.
MESSAGE NUMBER IN CORK. QUIRK I
REYES. SANTIAGO KING. I SEVEN
ZERO KNOWS. THAT BILL WILL BE
ON CALL. THANK YOU REMEMBER ONE
TO ITEM NUMBER. FIVE EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY MISTER
VIA COULD DO A- LEADS LOUISE
COMMISSION MAYBE AND GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS FIRST I
WANT TO START BY THANKING
THINKING YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE TO
CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE. AND
AGREED TO TAKE IT- COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS S. STATED IN THE IN
ALICE'S. AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
ONE IS AN IMPORTANT BILL THAT
ADVANCES A MORE REGIONAL
DIVERSE APPROACH TO OPERATIONS
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. ANY
GUARANTEES APPROPRIATE AND
SUSTAINABLE INVESTMENTS FOR OUR
ENERGY AND INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS OF EVERY
COMMUNITY ACROSS THE STATE. IN
THE LAST SIXTEEN YEARS- THERE
IS HAS NOT BEEN A SINGLE
COMMISSIONER APPOINTED FROM SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY OR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY A RULE TOWN OR A LOW
INCOME DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
IT IS TIME THAT THE DECISION
MAKERS AT THE CPUC. TRULY
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF THE
CHALLENGES OF THE ENTIRE STATE.
SPECIFICALLY EIGHT B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE WILL REQUIRE AT
LEAST ONE CPUC APPOINTEE TO
RECITE IN EACH OF THE FOLLOWING
AREAS NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CENTRAL VALLEY AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS SIMILAR
SIMILAR TO CURRENT REGIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. BOARD OF EQUALIZATION.
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCE
BOARD. AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE
ALSO REQUIRES THAT THE C. P. U.
C. CONSIDERED MOVING ITS
HEADQUARTERS TO NORTHERN. THE
NORTHERN END OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY TO- EMBEDDING IN IT IN
IN THE IN A RICH AND DIVERSE
SEE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY
STOCKTON. THIS MOVE WOULD
REQUIRE WOULD BE REGULATED AND
THE STAFF STAFF DIRECTLY IN IN
CONTEXT WITH THE COMMUNITY THAT.
THAT HAVE VERY DIFFERENT NEEDS
IN THOSE IN THE BAY AREA AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE WILL
ENSURE THAT THE COMMISSION
HOUSE- FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE
WITH ALL THE REGIONALS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WITH FURTHER-
WE INVEST FURTHER GUARANTEE
APPROPRIATE AND SUSTAINABLE
INVESTMENTS FOR OUR ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT MEETS THE
NEEDS OF EVERY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IS EDUARDO
GONZALEZ INTERIM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AT CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESIDENT. THANK YOU WE
HAVE ONE PRIMARY WITNESSES
SUPPORT TESTIFYING BY PHONE FOR
MODERATOR PLEASE PURPORTED
EDUARDO GONZALEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
FRESNO. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE LORD
GONZALEZ INTERIM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE OFFICE MEDIAN
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AFTER THE
STATE ALSO REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP OF
SEVENTY DOLLARS. EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL TO ENSURE THAT
CPUC CONSIDERS THE NEEDS OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND OF EVERY TO
ME ACROSS CALIFORNIA NOT ONLY A
CYCLE IT'S ON THE BAY AREA. CPC
DECISIONS AFFECT EVERY PERSON
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND WE
MUST ENSURE THAT THE COMMISSION
HAS FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE WITH
ALL REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP THANK
YOU BALLOT PROVIDES AN
ORGANIZATIONAL FRAMEWORK FOR
CONNECTING COLLABORATING AND
ADVOCATING TO IMPROVE ISSUES
IMPACTING THE QUALITY OF LIFE.
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY THUS
EQUITABLE REPRESENTATION FOR
THE A. COUNTY CENTRAL VALLEY
REGION AT THE STATE LEVEL IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO OUR MEMBERS
REPRESENTING PUBLIC PRIVATE
SECTORS WITH SIXTY TWO CITIES
AND MORE THAN FOUR MILLION
RESIDENTS CALL SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY CALLED IT IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT IT IS STILL ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST. UNDER
REPRESENTED REGIONS IN
COMPARISON TO THE REST OF THE
STATE SPECIFICALLY EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE WILL
REQUIRE AT LEAST ONE SI PC
APPOINT TO RECITE IN EACH OF
THE FOLLOWING AREAS NORTON
CALIFORNIA CENTRAL VALLEY AND
CENTER SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
SIMILAR TO CURRENT REGIONAL
REQUIREMENTS THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AB FOUR FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE
WILL ALSO PASS WITH QC TO
CONSIDER MOVING THE OFFICE TO
NORTHERN END OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN ORDER TO HELP BRING
MORE REGIONAL DIVERSE
PERSPECTIVES TO THE ENERGY
NEEDS OF THE ENTIRE STATE.
ACHIEVING REGIONAL
REPRESENTATION WILL PROVIDE
DIVERSITY OF THOUGHT IT MORE
EXPENSIVE KNOWLEDGE OF UTILITY
AND ENERGY EXPENSES AND BRING
BETTER HOW THE SESSIONS
CALIFORNIA'S ACROSS STATE IN
THE LAST SIXTEEN YEARS CAN YOU
BELIEVE NOT ONE SINGLE
COMMISSIONER WAS APPOINTED FROM
CENTRAL VALLEY. EITHER WORLD
TOWN OR LOW INCOME. OR
DISADVANTAGED. IT IS TIME THAT
THAT THIS IS MAKERS ARE THE C.
P. TRULY UNDERSTAND THAT NEEDS
AND CHALLENGES OF THE ENTIRE
STAY. BY ENSURING THAT COME.
HAS FIRST TIME NEXT WITH ALL
REGIONS CALIFORNIA WHICH
FURTHER KERN A PRO SUSTAINABLE
AND THAT'S- OF OUR ENERGY INTO.
THAT MEETS THE OF EVER
CALIFORNIA COMMUTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL NOW
OPEN IT UP FOR COMMENT DO WE
HAVE ANY. IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAIN OR THE GALA AND SUPPORT
OFFICE TO. I AM BE. THREE NINE
WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES THAT WISH TO TESTIFY
ON BEHALF. IN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ARE MEETING OF AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE. BONTA
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT ADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE IF IN ZERO
ACTIVE TIME. FOR MODERATE WILL
TAKE SUPPORT OPPOSITION OR
ANYONE WITH THE TURNS AT THE
SAME TIME. OKAY SO IF ANYONE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
TO ZERO AT THIS TIME. OPEN THE
LINE OF LINE NUMBER TWO NINE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS NIKOLINA
AS NONDESCRIPT BENDIGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC AND WE SUPPORT THAT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT THANK
YOU. ANECHOIC ORDER LINE NUMBER
SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JOSHUA
RESNICK TEN YEARS IN THE SOLAR
INDUSTRY SUNDRIDGE AND STRONGLY
OPPOSED AT ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
BECAUSE WOULD KILL. ONE HUNDRED
NINE MODERATOR NEXT PERSON.
THIS IS AB FORTY WHAT A LINE UP.
THE LADY TO DOUBLE AS A
REMINDER IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION OF
BILLING AB ONE FOUR SEVEN ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER SEVEN
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. OKAY THEY HAVE REMOVED
THEMSELVES FROM Q. WILL OPEN UP
MY NUMBER SEVEN FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. YES SERVICES
OMAR REPRESENT COMMUNITY SOLAR
DIRECTED BY STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
AB THIRTY NOT. OKAY IN THE BILL
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF BILL EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AT
THIS TIME. OKAY SB ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AND OPEN MY NUMBER
SEVEN NINETEEN REMINDED THE
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS RUBIO MARK
I LIVE IN MODESTO CALIFORNIA
AND I HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE
ISSUES OF BLACK REPRESENTATION
SO I SUPPORT EIGHTY EAST.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE. I'M READY
TO JUMP TO ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR BILL AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE
NEXT OPEN UP Y. NUMBER EIGHT
ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
ERICA STRIKER WITH CAPITAL
CITIES SOLAR FROM WRESTLE
CALIFORNIA AND WE- GREATLY
OPPOSE AB ONE ONE THREE NINE.
NEXT PERSON PLEASES AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE I WILL PLEASE
AFTER WE HAVE KNOWN ALL ALONG
TO BE AWARE WE ARE ONLY TAKING
COMMENTED AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
ONE. IF YOU ARE TESTIFYING IN A
DIFFERENT COLOR A BILL PLEASE
WAIT TILL THE BILL IS BEING
PRESENTED. OKAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR EIGHTY ONE FOUR
SEVEN ONE. PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. SB ONE OTHER PLACE WE
HAVE ONE PERSON IS DEAD AFTER
CURRENTLY WITH AN OPERATOR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE ONE
SEVEN NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. MY NAME IS ISAAC
LIEBERMAN I'M A MEMBER OF THE
L. A. COUNTY DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL
COMMITTEE AND A DELEGATE TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE. YOU KNOW WHAT I
THINK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU I DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. WE NEED A MOTION OUT
FAMOUS BARR QUE HAN. IT'S BEEN
MOTION BY MISS BURKE SECOND
THAT RAMOS CARILLO SPARKING ON
THE FOR SERVICE THANK YOU M.
THANK. FIRST I WOULD IMAGINE
THE PART OF THE BILL WHERE YOU
ASK FOR HAVING DIVERSITY ON THE
COMMISSIONERS I THINK THAT'S
REALLY CRITICAL FOR A WHOLE
HOST OF REASONS AND SOMEONE
MENTIONED TODAY AND EVEN IN MY
WORK HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE I
FIND THAT WHEN I TALK TO
PEOPLE. WHO LIVE IN DIFFERENT
UTILITIES YOUR GRAPHIC AREAS
THEY SEE IT DIFFERENTLY RIGHT
AND I JUST THINK THAT
REPRESENTATION IS REALLY
CRITICAL SO I THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE I DID WANT TO
ASK YOU TO DISCUSS A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHY WE WOULD BE MOVING
THE HEADQUARTERS A LOOK LIKE
THEREWOULDN'T BE AN INCREDIBLE
DESPITE THE FACT THAT I WAS
SURPRISED THAT WE WOULDN'T SEE
ANY. COST SAVINGS BY MOVING TO
STOCKTON IT APPEARED THE
ANALYSIS THAT THAT MAY BE THE
CASE AND I WHAT I DID SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF SEIU ONE THOUSAND
THAT WE WOULD BE DISPLACING
HUNDREDS OF WORKERS. WHO LIVE
AND WORK CURRENTLY IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND HAVE SPECIALIZED
SKILLS IN THIS. AND WHAT THAT
WOULD LOOK LIKE FOR THE WORKERS.
BERRIES ARE GIVE VERY VERY. I
MEAN IT'S WE'RE GETTING A LOT
OF FOLKS THAT ARE JUST MOVING.
ELSE ELSEWHERE FROM THERE AND-
I MEAN I HAVE EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND CARS THAT LEAVE. FROM
OUR DISTRICT OUT TO DRIVE. I
MEAN IT'S JUST GETTING TOUGHER
AND TOUGHER- MY DISTRICT IS A
MELTING POT I MEAN IT'S YOU YOU
NAME IT WE HAVE ACTED YOU NAME
WHATEVER RACE WE HAVE IT. AND I
JUST THINK THAT YOU KNOW WE
ALWAYS SEEM TO GET. PASSED OVER.
AND THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
YOU KNOW WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO PUT
STOCKTON ON THE MAP. BUT ALSO
NOT JUST STOCKTON RIGHT IT'S
JUST THIS IS REALLY TO
DIVERSIFY AND- TO WORK. WITH
WITH THROUGHOUT THE STATE NOT
JUST SAYING BAY AREA THIS ONE
AREA THIS IS THIS IS WE ARE.
WILLING TO YOU KNOW AT ANY THE
MINISTERS. THE WHOLE THING IS A
REALLY TO WORK WITH OTHERS. SO
I AM HERE I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE CONSIDER SPECIALLY
GIVEN THE COST OF KEEPING THAT
OFFICE SPACE IN SAN FRANCISCO
AT THE STATE BUILDING ISN'T
INCREDIBLY HIGH BASED ON THE
ANALYSIS. THAT WE ALLOW THE
WORKERS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BASED THERE. TO A POTENTIALLY
STAY THERE AND MAYBE HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL YOU KNOW WE HAVE
OFFICES IN LA SACRAMENTO AND
SAN FRANCISCO RIGHT NOW AND
LOOK AT THE OPTION OF ADDING
BUT NOT DISPLACING ALL THOSE
WORKERS I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T DISRUPT
THEM ANDTHEIR FAMILIES. AND WE
KEEP THE CONTINUITY OF THEIR
EXPERTISE. THANK YOU. THE COURT.
THE AUTHOR HOW TO SACRAMENTO
CAPT IS IT BAY AREA ORG CENTRAL
VALLEY- SACRAMENTO YEAH. WE
CALL THAT PART OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT IT'S PART OF THE
CENTRAL OKAY SO A MAJORITY OF
THE COMMISSIONERS COME FROM
SACRAMENTO WHAT'S THE PROBLEM.
WELL I MEAN I DO WE DO WE NEVER
HAVE HAD ANYONE ON THE
COMMISSION. YOU GO UP TO.
BAKERSFIELD YOU KNOW- FRESNO
STOCKTON WE'VE NEVER HAD ENDED
IT JUST AGAIN LIKE I SAID IT IT
JUST SEEMS THAT. THIS YEAR IT
JUST SEEMS TO GET PASSED OVER
YOU KNOW SO I'M REALLY TRYING
TO FIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT I'M
NOT TRYING TO TAKE AWAY FROM ME
ANY OTHER. CITIES I'M TRYING TO
MAKE THIS UNIFIED. FACT THAT
OUR CITY ALSO. IS LIKE I SAID
IT'S A MELTING POT YOU KNOW
THIS IS THIS IS THESE ARE. OUR
COMMUNITY SHOULD BELONG. AND
THAT'S WHAT I TRY TO DO IS
PUSHED OUT MAKE SURE THAT
HAPPENS. THANK THANK YOU. I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY I APPRECIATE THE EQUITY
COMPONENT THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS YOUR BILL HAVE A
COMMUNITY THAT'S OFTEN LOOKED
LOOKED PAST THE AND NOT
INCLUDED SO IF YOU DID THAT I
DO HAVE SOME CURRENT CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT PART OF THOSE
FILLING IN THOSE SCHOOLS BEING
LOST- WHEN WE'RE DISCUSSING
MOVING THE AGENCY AND I DO
APPRECIATE THAT MA'AM AS YOU
TAKE AND THAT IT'S ONLY A
CONSIDERATION AND NOT A
MANDATE- AND THERE BUT- AS THIS
BILL PROCEEDS UNDER DISCUSSION
FOR A PROCEED- I THINK AT SOME
POINT MAYBE CONSIDERING IF-
CONVOLUTED IN THE CONVERSATION
AS WE'RE TRYING TO ELEVATE. ED
WILL NEED- FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- SO WITH THAT I SEE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NINE. THANK YOU WE HAVE
WE DO HAVE A MOTION RIGHT YEAH
THANK YOU REMIND ME I WE DO
HAVE A MOTION- AND SO THE
MOTION IS THE PATH AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I AND NUMBER
FIVE AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CRISTINA GARCIA I CRISTINA
GARCIA I'D PATTERSON. PATTERSON
I'D BARRICADE HIM BETTER QUE
HAN I BURKE. BURKE I CARILLO
CARILLO I SHALL CHAU CHEN. CHEN
AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I
EDUARDO GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA
I MAYES. MAYES I MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI AYE CORK. QUIRK NOT
VOTING REYES. SANTIAGO KING.
FIVE ELEVEN ZERONOS THANK YOU
THINK THAT BILLS THAT WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS NEXT WE HAVE ITEM. SIX
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
BY BARKHANE HAN ELECTRICITE
RESOURCE ADEQUACY REQUIREMENTS
YOU MAY BEGIN THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL AND
DISCUSSING IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION THAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US AND I WANT TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENT. TODAY
PROUD TO PRESENT EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN AS A NEEDED STEP
FORWARD TO RELIABLE CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIA
LAST SUMMER WE SAW DRASTIC
RESULTS OF THE FAILURES IN OUR
SYSTEM WITH EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOMES AND BUSINESSES
LOST POWER FULLER GLOBAL
COMMUNITIES WERE LEFT IN THE
DARK IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC AT THE SAME TIME WE
HAD ENOUGH ENERGY STORED IN
BEHIND THE METER STORAGE OR IN
OUR BATTERY SUPPLIES. TO SUPPLY
COMMUNITIES WITH THE CRITICAL
NEEDED POWER THE HORRIBLE
BLACKOUTS WERE SYMPTOM OF
LARGER ISSUES WITH HIGH DEMAND
CALIFORNIA IS THE COUNTRY'S
NUMBER ONE ENERGY IMPORTER A
QUARTER OF OUR ENERGY IS
IMPORTED FROM OUT OF STATE AND
HIGH COST OF REPAIRS HOWEVER WE
HAVE PLENTY OF ENERGY FROM
SOLAR DURING THE DAY BUT NO
ACCESS TO THAT ENERGY ONCE IT'S
STORED IN BATTERIES AT NIGHT
THERE IS NO NEED TO BUILD A NEW
POWER PLANT- BY MORE ENERGY
FROM UTAH AND COLORADO. WE HAVE
THE ENERGY WE NEED SOARED IN
THE THOUSANDS OF BATTERIES AT
HOMES. AND BUSINESSES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AB FOR TWENTY
SIMPLY REQUIRES THE P. YOU SEE
EACH DEVELOP REGULATIONS. TO
FULLY UTILIZE THE RELIABLE
CLEAN ENERGY STORED IN BEHIND
THE METER BATTERIES. THESE
BATTERIES WILL SHORE UP THE
GRID AND OFFSET THE PRICE
SPIKES. THAT AREPASSED ON TO
RATEPAYERS AND I THINK THAT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT POINT WHEN WE
HAVE THESE ENERGY SPIKES
BECAUSE THERE IS A MASSIVE
DEMANDED ENERGY. WE PAY THE
HIGHEST COSTS FOR ENERGY TO
IMPORTED FROM OUT OF STATE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CHARTS OF
WHAT WE WERE PAYING IN AUGUST
FOR ENERGY. THAT IS CAUSING AN
INCREASE IN RATES THAT ARE
BEING PAID BY OUR CONSUMERS AND
IF WE CAN DRIVE THAT COSTS DOWN
BY USING BEHIND THE METER
ENERGY. R. COSTA REPAIRS WILL
GO DOWN. THE ENERGY NEWLY
AVAILABLE WILL HELP PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S MOST BLACKOUTS AND
THE REGULATIONS WILL LIKE CLEAN
ENERGY INSTALLATION MORE
AFFORDABLE. STORAGE IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE. THIS BILL
ALLOWS US TO STEP UP AND
UTILIZE THE STORAGE WE ALREADY
HAVE. THE BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
CLEAN ENERGY ADVOCATES IN
INDUSTRY AND WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT- LIST OUST. BOARD
PRESIDENT OF THE RANDY UNION
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND RACHEL.
MCMAHON SENIOR MANAGER OF
PUBLIC POLICY FOR SON RYAN. WHO
ALSO BE ON THE LINE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
TO SUPPORT TESTIFYING BY PHONE.
ONE MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE HE
OF RACHEL MIKE MY HON ON BEHALF
THE SUN RUN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS RACHEL CONFIRMING YOU
CAN HEAR ME YES. WONDERFUL HEY
THIS IS RACHEL MCMAHON SENIOR
POLICY MANAGER CRISPEN RUN WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL I THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BARRICADE HUNT FOR
OFFERING THAT SUPPORT
LEGISLATION. HER THOUGHTS VERY
GOOD METICULOUS THANK YOU TO
COMMITTEE BOB AND CHAIR FOR
PLACING EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN ON THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. THAT SOMEONE
THAT DEVELOPING VIRTUAL POWER
PLANT THE SINGLE FAMILY AND
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING UNDER
AGREEMENTS WITH MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES TREATED EACH RIGHT
AGGREGATORS AN INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES. A VIRTUAL POWER
PLANT IS MADE UP OF A LOT
INDIVIDUAL STORAGE SYSTEMS
LOCATED BEHIND THE CUSTOMER
METER AND THE SYSTEMS ARE
AGGREGATED TOGETHER AND ARE
OFFERED IN THE REPORT ADEQUACY
COMPETITIVE SOLICITATION HELD
BY UTILITIES. AND ELECTED
PROVIDE DISPATCHABLE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY CAPACITY THAT. CAN BE
CALLED ON WHEN NEEDED. WITH
RENTAL CAR HAD MULTIPLE.
THEY'RE NOT LOOK AIRPORT FROM
FOR CONTROL PLAY AND BY OPTION.
PROVIDE LOCAL RELIANCE. PROVIDE
ENHANCED TO BE AND ELECT SYSTEM.
ASSEMBLY RESILIENCY. AND
CUSTOMER LEVEL SERVICES AS
TRYING TO YOU FELT MANAGED PEAK
ROAD SHOW AN PROVIDING UP POWER
TO COST AND AMOUNT OF GRATITUDE.
WE NOW OUR FIRST CALL IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WITH EAST BAY
COMMUNITY ENERGY WHICH WILL BE
LOCATED ON SITE AND WEST
OAKLAND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
AREA AND WILL HELP TO OFFSET
THE LEGACY JET FUEL POWER
PLANTS IN THAT AREA WE SEEK OUT
PROJECTS. WITH SIMILAR
COMMANDED THAT. AND I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER K. MENTION DETECT
PROJECT ALTHOUGH HUGE POTENTIAL
FOR THE STATE AND COULD BE TO.
AGREE POWER TO CUSTOMERS AND
THE NEIGHBORHOODS PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF. AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THE FOR BACK UP
GENERATION. SO POWER PLANT
BECAUSE WITH THE- HELP THE
CALLOUS. BY CERTAIN. ON THE
CLASS TWENTY THREE PROJECTIONS
FROM THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION SHOW AT THIS TIME
RESOURCE ADEQUACY NEED HAVE
BETWEEN SEVEN THOUSAND AND- ONE
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS. JUST A FEW
SHORT YEARS FROM NOW. I
ANALYSIS TO THE BY RUN STATION
A AND NINETEEN FOUND THAT THE
TECHNICAL. FOR VIRTUAL POWER
PLANT WITH ABOUT NINE THOUSAND
MAKE A LOT STATEWIDE. THE THREE
THIRTY THAT ARE CLOSE TO LOAD
AND DO NOT REQUIRE ANY
TRANSMISSION OF ANTICIPATION WE
CONTROL OUR BATTERIES REMOTELY
AND GET INSIGHT INTO HOW MUCH
POWER THE BATTERIES HAVE AND-
ANY GIVEN TIME. AND IMPORTANTLY
WE'RE ABLE TO DISPATCH OUR
BATTERIES CAN MEET OUR REPORTS
ADEQUATELY OBLIGATIONS WITHOUT
HARMING THE CUSTOMER. NOT A
MAJOR BARRIERS FOR THE PRODUCTS
WHICH EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
TO LEVY A IS THAT BEHIND IT OR
STORAGE SYSTEM DO NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE A CAPACITY OF METHODOLOGY
TO QUALIFY FOR REFER SIDE OF
THE CITY AND WHAT THIS MEANS
AS- THEY DO NOT COUNTY MARIE
PHOTOGRAPHY PROSPECTUS. TODAY
VIRTUAL POWER PLANT PROJECTS
MISUSED THE METHODOLOGY
DESIGNED FOR DEMAND RESPONSE
RESOURCES WITH YOU THE BASIC
PLAN APPROACH AND DO NOT
RECOGNIZE ANY EXPORT FROM THE
FUNDS TO THE GRAD. NOT TAKEN
TOGETHER THESE TWO ELEMENTS.
NEED A REDUCTION IN THE ACTUAL
VALUE BY ANYWHERE FROM 6270%
DEPENDING ON THE CONFIGURATION.
NOW FOUR SEVEN WITH TERRIER BY
THE PC HAS SET UPON TO PASS BY
THE BEHIND METER STORE. IN
THAT'S EXPORT. IN THE FIFTH.
JUNE WERE REVERSED AFTER THAT
THE INTO TWENTY TO. FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE YEAR HOME
RUN OTHERS HAVING MULTIPLE
PROPOSAL AS THE PC 3% OF THE
PRECEDING AND WHILE ONE
WORKSHOP. IN NOVEMBER OF LAST
YEAR- BASED ON EVERYTHING WE
UNDERSTAND TODAY IT IS NOT
BEING ADDRESSED AND WILL NOT BE
IN THIS YEAR THE FISH ON HOW I
DID WANT TO SPEAK TO A FEW I
THINK MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT THE
PHONE. ON A REMAIN YOU HAVE
BEEN IN THIS LIMIT YOU COULD
PLEASE SEPARATE COMMONSENSE.
OKAY YES I HAVE ABOUT OR SO. ON
THE BILL WE NOT REQUIRE YOU TO
BUY CAPACITY BEHIND STORAGE BUT
IT WOULD ADVANCE BEHIND THE
METER STAR SYSTEM OVER OTHER
RESOURCES EITHER BY GETTING
THEM MORE VALUE OR A HIGHER
COST. I RECESSES WOULD STILL
HAVE TO BE SELECTED ON THE
COSTS AND BENEFITS WE BE
COMPETING WITH ALL OTHER
RESOURCES. AND FINALLY IT WOULD
NOT CIRCUMVENT ANY ANALYSIS BY
THE PC BUT BUILT NOT
PRESCRIPTIVE AND WOULD NOT
CIRCUMVENT STAFF ANALYSIS. FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT INTO THE PROCESS
ALL IT DOES THIS BY THE
DEADLINE. AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS THANK YOU. FOR
MODERATOR- WE HAVE LIST DOES.
WITH ARE IN THE UNION SCHOOL
DISTRICT YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. GREAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBERS MY NAME IS WITHOUT AND
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES FOR THE AROUND THE
UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT WERE
SMALLER DISTRICTS FEATURE
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
PUT FOUR ON THE STREET SCHOOL
ONE MIDDLE SCHOOL. AND WE'RE
LOCATED IN A HIGH FIRE THREAT
STONE WE ALSO HAVE A LIMITED
BUDGET ONE OF THE LOWER FUNDED
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE IN TERMS
OF OUR LTFS FUNDING. EIGHTY
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN. WOULD HELP
OUR DISTRICT TO GET TO GET ME.
PROVIDING RESILIENCY IN
CRITICAL BACKUP POWER TO OUR
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY. AT THE
SAME TIME THAT ENABLED US TO BE
USEFUL RESOURCE FOR THE GRIT.
WE HAVE FULLER SYSTEMS
INVOLVING ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS.
BUT ALONE THEY DON'T PROTECT
AGAINST POWER OUTAGES. ADDING
BATTERIES WOULD OFFER MANY
BENEFITS TO THE SCHOOLS IN THE
LARGER COMMUNITY. MAKING A MUCH
MORE RESILIENT. AND SEVERE HEAT
ENERGY TO IS USUALLY HIGHER
AFTER SCHOOL IS OUT FOR THE
DAY. WHEN SCHOOL BATTERY CAN
SUPPLY ENERGY TO THE GRID. ARE
GUESTS ARE GIVEN FORTUNATELY
INDOOR MULTIPLE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF. AND IT HAD TO
CANCEL SCHOOL CUTTING LOCKS
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME SERIOUS
DISRUPTIONS FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
BLACKOUT CURRENTLY MEAN THE
LOSS OF ESSENTIAL INSTRUCTIONAL
DAYS IN AN UNSAFE ENVIRONMENT
FOR TEACHING AND LEARNING.
DURING THE PAST YEP YEP AND
THEN WE HAD TO RELY ON
EMERGENCY GENERATORS AND
SPAGHETTI SAUCE ON SERVICE. THE
GLOBAL LACK OF LIGHT
VENTILATION IN CLASSROOM WE
CHOSE TO TEACH DURING THE
OUTAGES. BIRTH CONTROL
COMPLETELY. DESPITE MANY
BENEFITS. ARE DIFFERENT
CURRENTLY CAN TO ADD BATTERY
BECAUSE THE FOR CALL FOR Q. AB
TWENTY SEVEN COULD CHANGE THAT
BY ALLOWING THE BATTERY
CAPACITY. THE VALUE OF BATTERY
MAKES BETTER FINANCIAL SENSE.
WE JUST GOT THE ENERGY STORAGE
WITH PROVIDERS MORE CONFIDENT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
COMPETENTLY MANAGE OUR SYSTEM
IN RESPONSE TO GREAT NEEDS. THE
TIME WHEN THE GRAINY POWER THAT
WE HAVE SOARED WE WANT TO BE A
PUBLIC REPORT ESPECIALLY THE
TIMING OF PEAK DEMAND PERIOD.
WORKS SO WELL WITH OUR SCHOOL
HOURS. ADDED VALUE THIS BILL
WOULD HELP PROVIDE IN ORDER TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN FOR OUR
DISTRICT. AS WELL AS OTHERS IN
HIGH FIRE THREAT STONE. PLEASE
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR TO
SEVEN THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER. OR IN THE GALLERY AND
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OR IN
BETWEEN. SEEN NONE WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON HELLO. GO AHEAD FEDERAL
CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN OPPOSITION EIGHTY FOUR TO
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE
FIRM OF THE PHONE LINES ARE NOT
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON
AB FOUR TO SEVEN ON SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ARE IN BETWEEN ONE
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON
THE LINE. YES MA'AM WE DO
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY
IT SHOULD BE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OR IN
BETWEEN FOR BILL NUMBER. EIGHTY
FOUR TWO SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHILE
OPEN UP MY NUMBER FOUR NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HAPPEN
BOARD ECONOMIC HALF OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN OPPOSITION.
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHT ONE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUSTIN HIGHER
FROM THE BILL COMBINE
READERSHIP GROUP ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU. Y.
EIGHT ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF
OF AND FEET AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA EFFICIENCY DEMAND
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
MY NUMBER EIGHT ONE SIX YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU
SURE MEMBERS JOINING US TO
RESET WITH THE WHITE MAN GROUP
ON BEHALF OF EAST BAY COMMUNITY
ENERGY IN SUPPORT. WHY NUMBER
TWO FIFTY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS DELANEY
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. WHY NUMBER
EIGHT ZERO SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. JOHN HART WITH EDF
RENEWABLES STRONG SUPPORT. MY
NUMBER ONE THREE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. SCHRODER
NEWMAN NAY COULD MARTINEZ- WITH
IBEW AND STRICKLAND OPPOSITION
FOR THE BILL. THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH OVERSIGHT BUT AN
ORDINARY PERSON. MY NUMBER
EIGHT ONE FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. CAROL REED WITH THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY FORTY SEVEN.
LINE ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. THANK YOU CAN STONE
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION PROP FOSTERS IN
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER ONE OH SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON GIVING A
PLUMBING SOMETHING HAPPENS AT
THE GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY-
AFTER REVIEWING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENT WHICH
ADDRESS OUR PRIMARY CONCERN-
WE'D LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL- AND WE'D LIKE TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SOME
ADDITIONAL REFINEMENTS THAT WE-
LIKE TO SPEAK TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU. ONE NUMBER THREE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
MARGARET MILLER WITH ANGIE
NORTH AMERICA IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
ONE THREE TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT LILLIAN MURPHY WITH THE
CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOUNG. ONE THREE FIVE FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN POLICY OR
NOTHING RIGHT. ONE THREE FIVE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NOT RESPONSIBLE
ONE POINT NUMBER FOUR FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THAT STILL BE OFFERING TO
HAPPEN SOME POWER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER SIX TWO
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR MIND OPEN. NUMBER
TWO FOUR THANK YOU. YEAH WE CAN
HEAR YOU. THANKS AFTERNOON
PALATINE ON BEHALF OF AND
THEY'LL NORTH AMERICA IN
SUPPORT. ONE SEVEN NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THIS IS
RUBEN WILL MARCH I WORK FOR L.
G. ENERGY STORAGE GROUP- I
AGREE WITH THE PREMISE THAT I
SUPPORT AB FOUR TO SEVEN. NINE
SEVEN NINE ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ISAAC
LIEBERMAN THE NUMBER THE L. A.
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
DELEGATES THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY. MEMBER OF
SEIU SEVEN TWENTY ONE I WANT TO
SAY THAT I SUPPORT EIGHTY FOUR
TO SEVEN AND OF MY BROTHERS AND
COULD. NOT BE DONE YET. MY
NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON-
HUNTER STERN IBEW LOCAL TWELVE
FORTY FIVE IN OPPOSITION. WHY
NUMBER EIGHT NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. EIGHT NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF YOUR MIND
IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR
YOU. THIS IS JOHN WHITE FOR THE
CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. ONE EIGHT TWO FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. SHARE
MEMBERS THIS IS BACK UP INTO
THE CALIFORNIA VISORS I'LL BE
HAPPY THAT BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. ONE EIGHT TWO SIX YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THAT IN TURN
MEMBERS STAND TRIAL THE TEST
WELL IN SUPPORT. NINE EIGHT TWO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
ONE EIGHT IS THAT ME. IT IS.
OKAY SORRY DIDN'T DASH
WATERBURY- KEEP A DELEGATE TO
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
SUNRISE COORDINATOR IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND OPPOSING BILL
ONE ONE THREE NINE THANK. ONE
THREE FOUR SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GRAYSON REPRESENTING
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AND THE
BILL. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION OR
IN THE MIDDLE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO FOOTBALL AB FOUR TO SEVEN.
Y. EIGHT TWENTY REMINDED ABOUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBER
AND CHAIR IGOR TRACK OF BLOOD
MEMBER AT THAT CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ENVIRONMENTAL
CAUCUS BUT SPEAKING AT THE
INDIVIDUAL AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE PERSON
IN Q. THE CROWD WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE
THREE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE THREE FIFTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JOHN DORY WITH
SUN RUN IN SUPPORT. ONE ONE
NINE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS PAUL BEESON WITH
GARBAGE IN SOLAR ELECTRIC IN
SUPPORT OF. IN SUPPORT OF THE
CURRENT BILL. NINE EIGHT
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE HOLDS
EIGHT AROUND WHAT THE COSMIC
SOLAR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR TO SEVEN THANK YOU. AND AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN HERE. THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. MISTER PARK. TERRACE
IS PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD WE
ALLOW RIGHT NOW THE I SO WHEN
IT'S LOOKING AT DEMAND AND
THINKS IT'S GOING TO BE- HIGHER
THAN WE CAN GENERATE VAST
PEOPLE NOT TO USE- THE ENERGY
THAT THEY COULD IN RETURN THEY
GET A DISCOUNT. THAT'S FINE.
BUT AND I'M ALSO FINE WITH
FRANKLY PUTTING THE DEADLINE ON
THE CHAMBER ON THE COMMISSION
THE PROBLEM I HAVE HERE IS ON
PAGE FOUR LINE TWENTY NINE.
SAYS A STATUS RULES THAT ALLOW
DEMAND RESPONSE PROGRAMS AND
RESOURCES PROCURED BY A LOAD
SERVING ENTITY TO MAKE THE LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES RESOURCE
ASKING. ADEQUACY REQUIREMENTS
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
PROGRAM IS INTEGRATED INTO THE
WHOLESALE MARKET. OVERSEEN BY
THE ACT INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATOR IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
LEAVES A BIG HOLE. BECAUSE IF
THE INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATORS NOT PART OF IT HOW
DOES IT BALANCE LOADS. YEAH SO
PER COMMITTEE MANAGER ACTUALLY
STRIKING THAT SO YOU YOU ARE
FOURTEENTH ACTUALLY WHAT THE
COMMITTEES SITE AND WE'RE
LEAVING- SO THE MEAT OF THE
BILL IS NOW ON THIS PAGE SEVEN
K. WHICH CREATES V. M. BUT
CAPACITY VALUATION METHODOLOGY.
INTERESTS ARE CONCERNED YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU GOT GOING HERE IN
MY FOR HERE I'M SORRY I HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT YOU SAID OKAY. CAN I
REPEAT. OKAY THE AMENDMENTS
WHAT YOU ARE CONCERNED ABOUT IS
PART OF WHAT WE STRUCK FROM THE
BATTLE HE DID STRIKE OUT OF THE
WELL THAT'S GREAT- THAT MAKES
THINGS A LOT MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD. THE OTHER
CONCERN I HAVE IS. SO WE HEARD
FROM THE SCHOOL AND THEY WANT
THEIR BATTERY BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO BE ABLE TO EDUCATE THEIR
KIDS WHEN THERE'S A POWER SHOT
OFF. AND THAT MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE SO THEY MAY HAVE KIDS
STARTING AT EIGHT OR NINE IN
THE MORNING GOING TO THREE
THIRTY THERE'S A POWER SHOT OFF.
THE TIME WHEN YOU MOST NEED
PEOPLE TO BRING DOWN THEIR
LOADS IS WHAT'S CALLED THE
NAKED ATTACK BUT BASICALLY IT'S
A PERIOD WHEN THE SUN GOES DOWN
UNTIL AROUND SIX OR SEVEN AT
NIGHT THAT'S WHEN THE LOW JUST
GOES LIKE CRAZY. THE PROBLEM IS
THE I SO WILL NOT KNOW THAT
THAT BATTERY. WAS USED BY THE
SCHOOL. OR PERHAPS IN THE WHOLE
REGION THAT'S LOW ON POWER THEY
HAVE A WHOLE POWER SHUT OFF IN
THE ISO JUSTICE AGAIN NO THIS.
BECAUSE THE ISO DOESN'T KNOW
IT'S LIKELY TO SAY OVER FINE.
WE HAVE ALL THESE BATTERIES
THAT CAN COME ONLINE AND THEY
CAN'T. SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
SORT OF PRACTICAL CONSIDERATION
I'M WORRIED ABOUT YEAH AN
OSTRICH MCMAHON TO ADDRESS THAT
CENTER AND ACTUALLY HAS AN
INTEREST MODEL I DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT FOR WORKING ON THIS BILL
WHERE THEY CONTROL THE
BATTERIES SO THEY WITHHOLD
ABOUT FIFTY REGIONAL CORRECT ME
IF I'M WRONG BUT 50% FOR. THE
SCHOOL AND TO THE HOME TO USE
BUT THE REST IS ACTUALLY
CONTROLLED TO PROVIDE THAT
ADEQUACY AND THEY GUARANTEE IT
AND REGIONAL CAN ELABORATE ON
THAT BUT IT ADDRESSES EXACTLY
CONCERNED YOU'RE- DISCUSSING
YOUR HAVE TO ELABORATE ON. THE
FOR THE BILL OKAY. THANK YOU MY
SURPRISE. THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS MISS REYES. THANK YOU
MANAGER I DO KNOW THAT THE BILL
HAS BEEN AMENDED- QUITE A BIT
AND HAS ADDRESSED SOME OF THE
ISSUES- FROM. THE UTILITY
WORKERS I B. W. AND OTHERS WHO
WORK ON ON THIS. ON THE VERY
PROJECTS I- AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT THE- AMENDMENTS HAVE
ACTUALLY TAKEN CARE OF MOST
EVERYTHING AND I JUST IT IF
THERE ARE STILL ISSUES
LINGERING I KNOW THAT. YOU'RE
HAVE COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
THOSE. YES THANK YOU MANDATORY
LATER WE- WE INVITE IBEW IN THE
BUILDING TRADES TO PLEASE ME
WITH MY OFFICE WE WERE TRYING
TO BE WITH THEM AND WE DO WANT
TO HEAR THEIR CONCERNS AND WE
ARE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THEM.
AND AS YOU MENTIONED THE MENACE
TAKEN HEARING COMMITTEE ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS OF BOTH P. JEANNIE
AND THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS AND I WANT TO THANK
THEM FOR THEIR WORK WITH ME ON
THE COMMITTEE TO GET THEM. TO A
PLACE WHERE THEY'RE COMFORTABLE
WITH THE BILL AND I HOPE WE CAN
GET- THE WORKERS THERE AS WELL.
THANK YOU I WILL BE SUPPORTING.
THE BILL TODAY AND- RESERVE. MY
FINAL COMMENT ON THE ON THE-
THE FLOOR BASED UPON. THE WORK
IT WILL BE DONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. IS CARILLO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF OUR MAJORITY LEADER
AND IN ADDRESSING TO THE AUTHOR
THAT I HOPE THAT YOU DO I
CONTINUE THE WORK THAT MUCH
NEEDED WITH LABOR WE JUST HAD A
VERY ROBUST CONVERSATION AND
DISCUSSION ON THAT ENERGY
MEETING AND SOLAR COMPANIES
ALSO UNDERSTANDING THE VERY
REAL CHANGES THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN WHEN IT COMES TO EQUITY
AND ENERGY AND SO THESE ARE I
THINK CONSTANT CONVERSATIONS IN
REAL TIME CONVERSATIONS THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TO INSURE
THAT YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK IT AND- GET TO
A GOOD PLACE AND HOPE THAT
YOU'RE THERE. BY THE TIME IT
REACHES OUR ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
THANK YOU. HANKINS CRAFT. OKAY
SCENE NO MORE COMMENT DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. MOVED BY MR TANG
SECOND AMBER MISS BURKE. MIKLOS
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA RESS
MISCREANTS COMING QUICKLY WHICH
IS TO SAY I AGREE AND AS YOU
HEARD IN MY COMMENTS- I MISSED
GONZALEZ IS BILL ACTUALLY I
MEAN THIS PART OF COULD
ACTUALLY ALREADY PREVENTS COST
SHIFTING AND LIKE I SAID I
ACTUALLY THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT EFFORT AND DRIVING
DOWN COSTS FOR COMMUNITIES
THERE ARE YOU SUFFERING WITH
BILLS THAT ARE TOO HIGH. AND
THAT'S TE EFFORT HERE AND IF
LABOR HAS WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN
IMPROVE THAT I INVITE IT AND I
HOPE WE WILL GET THERE SO I
REALLY THINK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I WOULD.
THINK YOU THE MOTION IS TO PASS
WITH AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
I AM NUMBER SIX EIGHTY FOUR TO
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
MANDATORY PROBATION CRISTINA
GARCIA I. CRISTINA GARCIA I
PATTERSON. BARRICADE HIM.
BURGER K. HAN I BURKE. BURKE I
CARILLO. I SHALL CHAU CHEN.
CHEN NO. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
NO EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA I MAYES. MAYES NOW MAYES
NOW. NOT VOTING. MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I COURT. I REYES
REYES I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I.
CHING HAI. IS ELEVEN KNOWS TO
THANK YOU THAT PHYLLIS OUT
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS OF THE TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE WE STILL HAVE TWO MORE
BILLS AND SO I WILL PASS IT
OVER TO FOR ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
TWO MISTER BATES FIRE SAFETY
ELECTRICAL TRANSMISSION OR
DISTRIBUTION LINES CLEARANCES I
DO APPRECIATE YOUR BREVITY. IT
DOES GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR- IN CONSIDERATION OF OUR
TIME I'M NOT GONNA READ MY
ENTIRE BUILDINGS WHICH I'M SURE
YOU'LL APPRECIATE- I WOULD- AND
THEN ANSWER CUNNINGHAM AND
SECONDED BY MISS BURKE I WILL
JUST WANT TO SAY WE WILL GLADLY
ACCEPTS- AS A COMMITTEES.
AMENDMENTS AND- I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF FOLKS THAT WANT TO.
PROVIDE A TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
A SURVEY WHICH IS GOING TO LINE.
THANK YOU I WILL- MOVE ON WE
HAVE WITNESSES HERE AND THE
CHAMBERS IN THE GALLERY SCOTT
WHICH AND WE HAVE A COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA. UTILITY
EMPLOYEES I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
BREVITY AS WELL YOU MAY PROCEED
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GOT WHICH
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
UTILITY EMPLOYEES. OUR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT CREWS ARE
FACING HUGE OBSTACLES IN
GETTING IN AND DOING THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT THAT WE
ALL WANT AND NEED THEM TO DO.
THIS BILL IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO HELP ALLEVIATE
THIS PROBLEM SOME READERS I'VE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR SECOND-
PRIMARY WHEN THEY IS A- IF
JUSTIFY BY. FOR MODERATOR
PLEASE PUT UP MISTER CHRIS
POTTER WITH P. AFTERNOON MEMBER-
BUT CHAIR BY CHAIR MANY CHRIS
I'M HAPPY ALL PEOPLE AS WELL-
OVER THE LAST YEARS- THERE'S
VERY COMMITTEE- AND ALLEGED.
TAKEN FRANKLY THE RIGHT OUT
WITH TO- AND THE WAY WITH IT TO
BE IN THE WAY MITIGATION BASED.
HOWEVER I WE CONTINUE TO DO
THAT WORK AND HE- THE VERY
BODIES WE ARE NOT RUNNING INTO
A NUMBER OF HURDLES A NUMBER
ONE OF WHICH THE BILL. TRIED TO
ADDRESS AND SO- GIVEN THAT- WE
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AS WE- TRY TO REMOVE A
CRITICAL BARRIER TO THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WORK YOU
WOULD WANT THE I ARE USED TO BE
DOING TO MINIMIZE. CATASTROPHIC.
FIRES IN THE STATE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
PRIMER WITNESS AND I'LL- WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER FLOOR OR IN
THE GALLERY. THAT WISH TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OR AGAINST AB FOUR
FOUR EIGHT. C. N. AND NINE AT
WE WILL MOVE ON. THE PHONE
LINES ARE NOT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON AB FOUR FOUR
EIGHT POINT FOR MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE THE LINE THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK AND SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ARCHER CONCERNS ON
AB FOUR FOUR EIGHT. YES MA'AM
WE DO. AND LIKELY TO DOMINATE
THE REMINDER IF YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
OR IN BETWEEN FOR EIGHTY FOUR
FOUR EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MY NUMBER
TWO NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS TO OBSERVERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SPORT THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER TWO NINE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON COOLEY NOW WITH A
LOOK ATHLETIC IMPORTANCIA. MY
NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES HUNTER STERN IBM
BE TWELVE FORTY FIVE IN SPORT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OR IN
BETWEEN FOR BILL AB FOUR FOUR
EIGHT THREE FIVE ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK THANK YOU WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. BECAUSE THE
BILL BEEN MOVED. YEAH
CUNNINGHAM CHEN YES DEFINITELY
THANK YOU. AT THE SCENE AND
NINE THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS WOULD BE LIKE TO
CLOSE SURE THANK YOU VENTURE
CONSISTENT WITH THE LEXMARK
POLICIES I CREATED- IN SB NOT
ALIGNED AND AB TEN FIFTY FOUR-
THIS BILL AB FOUR PARADE
CONTINUES- THAT WORK RESPECT
REQUEST AND I BOTH. THANK YOU
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS A
NATURAL RESOURCES WITH THE
AUTHORS COMMITMENT THAT THE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN IN
NATURAL RESOURCES SECRETARY
LEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR FOUR
EIGHT THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
WITH AUTHORS COMMITMENT TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS AND NATURAL
RESOURCES. CRISTINA GARCIA HI.
GARCIA I. PATTERSON PATTERSON I
BETTER CAN PARA QUE HAN I BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO. CARRILLO HIGH
CHAO. JOE HI CHEN CHEN AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I EDUARDO
GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA I'D
MAYES. MAYES EIMER CG RCG I
CORK. CORK IRATE IS. PRESS AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I THINK.
CHANGE HI HIS FIFTEEN NO. ZERO
THANK YOU THAT FEEL F. L. LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN PERHAPS AND
MEMBERS WE WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB SIX FORTY ONE BY
MR HOLDEN TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION. LOCAL PUBLICLY
OWNED ELECTRIC UTILITIES AND
WILL BE PRESENTED BY FAMILY
WOMEN RIGHT IF. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
SHAREHOLDERS I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS IN COMMENTS NUMBER
THREE ON PAGE TWO. AS WE ALL
HAVE SEEN ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE
pAND MANUFACTURERS ARE
RESPONDING. THOSE DRIVERS HAVE
TO HAVE A PLACE TO CHARGE THEIR
VEHICLES WHEN THEY ARE ON THE
MOVE. BUILD OUT OF THOSE
CHARGERS IS OCCURRING IN MANY
AREAS AND WE ARE HEAVILY
RELYING ON THE STATE'S ELECTRIC
I'LL USE TO FILL THIS NEED. IN
FACT SEVERAL BILLS HAVE PASSED
REQUIRING THEM TO DO SO WE MUST
BE SURE THE PO USE ARE FILLING
THE GAP IN THEIR TERRITORIES.
THIS BILL WOULD DO JUST THAT BY
REQUIRING ALL PEOPLE USE TO
MAKE PUBLIC CHARGING AVAILABLE.
THEY HAVE FULL LATITUDE ON HOW
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN INCLUDING
CHARGING FOR THE SERVICE AND
WORKING WITH PRIVATE INDUSTRY
TO FEEL TO GET THE NEED. THEY
ALSO WILL. THE REQUIRED TO
CONSIDER THE BROADER NEEDS OF
THE CUSTOMERS FOR
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
THE FORM OF A PLAN. IN A PUBLIC
PUBLIC MEETING AND POSTED ON
THE INTERNET. THERE ARE NO
SERVICE MANDATES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE PLAN THEY JUST NEED TO
THINK ABOUT IT. THE AUTHOR HAS
WORKED WITH PO USE WHICH IS
REFLECTED IN THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ANALYSIS. AND THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BY MISTER. SANTIAGO. SECOND BY
MR QUIRK. DO WE HAVE ANYONE
THAT WANTS TO SPEAK O BEHALF
OR AGAINST THE BILL IN THE BACK
OF THE CHAMBER. OR IN THE
GALLERY SCENE. NINE THE PHONE
LINES ARE NOT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON AB SIX FOR
ONE PHONE MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE LINE THAT WISHES
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OR SEARCH SURE CONCERNS ON AB
SIX FORTY ONE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF EIGHTY SIX FOUR ONE THREE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AS
A REMINDER IF ELECTED BECAUSE
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
PRESS WHY DID ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO ONE ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE A
PROMOTION WOULD BE LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. WELL I APOLOGIZE MISTER
GORE GREATEST- MISTER CORRECT.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY JUST TO
COMMENT. YES THEY'LL CHARGE FOR
ELECTRICITY THERE'S GOING TO BE
ONE OTHER THING THAT HAPPENS
THEY'LL UP THEY'LL BE PLACES
WHERE YOU NEED TO PUT A NEW
TRANSFORMERS NEW OTHER NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE I DON'T WANT YOU
TO TAKE THAT UP NOW BUT IT'S
JUST A REMINDER THAT THERE ARE
MORE THAN JUST THE DIRECT COSTS
OTHER COULD BE VERY LARGE
INDIRECT COSTS IF WE HAVE TO
BUILD UP THE GRANT- WON'T ASK
YOU TO SOLVE THAT ONE. BUT IT'S
SOMETHING TO BE REMIND REMIND
THANK YOU I'LL BE VOTING FOR
THE BILL. THANK YOU WILL SHARE
COMMENTS WITH MR HOLDEN- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CLOTHES SECRETARY
AT THE MOTION IS DUE PATH
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI ADAM NUMBER NINE SB SIX FOUR
ONE MOTIONS TO PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CRISTINA
GARCIA HI CRISTINA GARCIA I
PATTERSON. BETTER QUE HAN
AMERICA HAD AYE BURKE. BURKE I
CARILLO CORREO HI CHECK OUT.
CHEN CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HIGH
EDUARDO GARCIA. THEY WERE ORDER
GARCIA I'D MAYES. MAYES I
MURATSUCHI. MURATSUCHI AYE CORK.
BURKE I REYES. REYES AYE
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I THINK.
KING HI. HIS TWELVE NO ZERO
THANK YOU THE BILL IF OUT WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES OUR BILL
PRESENTATIONS FOR TODAY WE WILL
NOW REOPEN OUR ROLE FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR A COMPLETE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS TO COMMITTEE.
UNDER SECRETARY ONE OF ONE.
THREE THREE ONE FILE ORDER. K.
CONSENT. CONSENT. VOTES AYE
LEVIN AYE AYES. ZERONOS CHILD.
CHAU HI EDUARDO GARCIA. EDUARDO
GARCIA I SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I
CHANGED THINGS HI. FIVE FIFTEEN
NO ZERO THE BILL WITHOUT I ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB. FIVE TWO FIVE.
THE MOTION IS DAY PASSES
AMENDED TO NATURAL RESOURCES.
IS THE LEVIN NO ZERO. EDUARDO
GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI TEAM.
CHIANG HI. IS FOURTEEN NO. ZERO
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE THE MEASURES DO
PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. I SEVEN ZERO
BARRICADE HAND. PARA QUE HANNAH
VOTING. EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA I MAYES MAYES I REYES.
REYES REYES AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I THINK. CHANG I. HIS
TWELVE NO ZERO THANK YOU THE
BILL WITHOUT. I DON'T NUMBER
FIVE A. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS I WAS ELEVEN NO
ZERO. REYES. REYES AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HIGH TEAM. CHAIN NOW.
IS THIRTEEN KNOWS ONE THANK YOU
THE BILL WITHOUT. THE ITEM
NUMBER SIX. AB FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS HIS
ELEVEN KNOWS TO. PATTERSON. HIS
ELEVEN KNOWS TO. THE WHOLE
THING. WE'LL KEEP THAT OPEN FOR
A MINUTE WE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ONE OKAY. FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
SB SIX FOUR ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. IS TWELVE NO
ZERO PATTERSON. CHAU CHAU AYE
CHAN. HIS THIRTEEN OH ZERO KEEP
THAT OPEN. I BELIEVE THAT- ITEM
OPEN FOR A MINUTE. THE BILL IS
OUT. THANK YOU. OKAY ON TWO
BILLS AND CHECK. OKAY. THEN IN
A THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED TO THE ENTIRE
STAFF- WE WILL ADJOURN TODAY'S
MEETING.